tout le monde est bienvenu pour ce
nouveau match de speechless bonsoir vlad
salut kery un salut tout le monde
lula dont on arrive aux demi finales
avec wesley so contre duda qui avait
bien d'éliminer ton poulain il est vrai
et ils avaient éliminé d'une manière
incontestable
on peut le dire n'ont en tout cas pas le
dire non on ne le dit pas il devrait
perdre en bien sûr gagner finalement
avec de la bonne chanson un peu pas dire
pas du tout par contre je dois me
retenir ce soir je suis pourri même si
je vois maintenant
d'après sa gueule et quel point lna duda
à quel point resterai simple d'euros
parce que je vois qu'il ou elle est là
comme d'habitude de son pot café 12
heures de toute évidence elle est très
très très sénat et donc je pense que
c'est la seule chose la seule chose qui
pourrait empêcher de gagner le stress la
pression le stress et les marques
d'expérience tout simplement parce que
sans même s'il est nettement moins doués
ou même s'il est moins net voire moins
impressionnant et les plus récents à
tanger juste de faire une petite virée à
une vérification de la con et vient d'en
ligne c'est pour ça que tu vois plus
l'écran mais je crois qu'on est en ligne
mais juge ne vérifie tu vois
et comme ça après on va être ensemble
pendant trois heures pour commenter le
match et là du coup tu as plus accès aux
têtes tu vois plus rien oui on est bien
en ligne donc c'est parfait blad ses
parfums docteur on entende que ce que
commence on attend qu'ils commenceraient
à genève aujourd'hui on voit
voir de la part de sault plutôt les
ouvertures firmin parce que je pense que
c'est bien ça plutôt le point sensible
aux noix il est plutôt fort dans les
positions 1 tactique est ouverte
duda général et les bons éléments comme
en moins prévisible les positions dans
les positions ouvertes parce que là et
il joue pas mal d ouverture elle se
débrouille plutôt bien et je pense qu'il
vaut mieux de le vérifier dans les 4 ha
tiens c'est comment ça va oui et ça
commence par rousseau limo variantes de
beauce couche sais pas comment
t'appelles 5-1 foulée cinq échecs au but
au parc comme enjeu la paix le maire ça
m'a surpris déjà le cas dans ce sens que
les trois ans de 6% il faut 200 faut
prendre cette balle de set 6 4 4 6 6
d'après ce que je sais ce n'est pas élue
meilleure ligne pour le noir mobo donc
des quintas a décollé de 4 l'élevage au
fusil c'est que les deux camps les 6 ha
tiens quand les deux donc là maintenant
si je me trompe pas la mort mais si je
me trompe pas d'un métier ségalis au
dessus mais c'est ce qui vient d'être
joué je sais pas si tu vois le truc
totalement directeur du site un petit
décalage par rapport à ce qu'on a sur
l'écran il est précis benoît d'après ce
que je sais des meshes égalise
déjà et donc au lieu de commander 2 2 x
3 est beaucoup plus haut beaucoup plus
haut comment s'appellent les challenges
ans donc je suis plutôt surpris de voir
cette foule a du coup là on arrive dans
une position qui encore théorique parce
qu'il ya eu des échanges acquis et des
cinq épreuves 4 les joueurs jouer assez
vite
est-ce que tu connais la ce qui est en
train de jouer oui bien sûr je connais
très bien je les ai sera pour une fois
j'ai jamais trouvé des idées
intéressantes pour les bois remet ça
veut dire quoi que peut-être aussi à
trouver des idées pratiques sur mon
expérience
ce n'est pas vraiment intéressant pour
les bois en poche que ok les noix on
prend une compensation pour les qualités
et y compris leurs massifs des pions
delesalle
il propose l'échangé damas et dan dan
dessin glad bien logique parce que bien
sûr chaque échange des pièces les chères
des pièces lourdes pour les noirs mais
que la finale avec deux pions contre
contre une qualité c'est censé être
mieux pour pour les deux purs et le
cavalier ouais c'est pas que mes yeux
c'est potentiellement mieux
potentiellement mis au point pour
l'instant mais en général bien sûr les
lois de quoi être fier pour le futur
c'est le massif de pions comme je viens
dit avant puis donc l'emplacement du roi
puis donc la colombe asséné ouverte pour
la tour enfin il ya de quoi être content
pour le futur donc il fait à trois pour
éviter de se faire fixé par des quatre
j'imagine je pense pas qu'elle va
répéter soutenir sur l'air à vrai dire
je ne pense pas qu'il rêve de se le dire
parce que bien sûr hui nos doutes at
comprennent que c'est pas le choix
critique eu l'avantagé pensions pas mal
de choses sont possibles de contact aura
8 qui est intercalé h5 peut-être même
rejailli d'ailleurs tour joué pendant
même temps je suis plus d'intérêts
possibles avec les des cavaliers est ce
que tu penses que maintenant après b 4
jeux quelque chose comme cavalier h5 ou
cavaliers 1,8 pour échanger les fous et
après rediriger un cavalier vers la
casse ces quatre peut-être mais il faut
être concret le problème c'est qu'après
à 3.461 jeu colère cinq mâts pas fou je
sais que relais je sais tu que les trois
gagnantes gros couac rauque et coller à
cette possible il vient de jeu sam c'est
pas beau je pense que non c'est moi qui
déplaçait les pièces un rapport dont je
pense que jean christophe devaux centre
ont pris là quelque part
pendant la dernière coupe à ce que je
pense que normalement on ne sait pas
quand même si tu envoies sotchi mais
accueillir le cas ici 3 qui avait dû
prendre b52 dérange bon sens moi tu
déranges je pense que comme ailleurs
j'ai bien raison que ça me dérange parce
que normalement le traite d'une manière
plus haut au plus haut plus haut plus
précises quoi donc tour à bâle et le
défendent leur fou sur hbo dôme haute
marc colom 8 et peut-être à ok j'ai
compris les 2 3 l'idée est de coller
wilson bien fou je sais qu'on l'ait je
sais que le soir quand le bocal temps
prend des quatre tours prend ses trois
tours prend des cinq tours c'est cette
juste à temps howie puis donc aucun
problème donc oui je veux pas pitié ni
la nier les autres mais il a fait
cavalier à 7
dans ce cas je comprends pas pourquoi
pas couru les blocages
peut-être à cause du pib 5 ok je bouge
mon corps mais il est très probable que
je vois pas quelque chose enfants dans
la dure on a dû on a dû rater quelque
chose craquer au sens me tournerai mais
tout est possible mais après tout c'est
scier ce qu'on réussisse je pense que ça
va plus loin pour le noir pour l'instant
je vois pas trop de danger donc je pense
que ça doit aller pour les noirs parce
que la tour éventuellement on peut
peut-être faire caler ses sept cavaliers
à huit qui avaient libéré six cavaliers
c4 aussi de témoigner voir me font
toujours pas perdu cavaliers des 5 et te
retrouver un jeu qu'on prend de telles
que j'allais m'en fout toujours plus ont
posté au moins il si c'est tout fait mal
même si
et à biot témoigne à l'égalité moitié et
en matériel je toujours pu emmener voir
lire vos trolls de 3,8 aux caisses pour
éviter cavaliers ces cinq échecs
j'imagine pourtant il est polonais ils
sont pas si j'aurais dit que c'est un
toc sont en majorité catholiques en
pologne à matam soir les progrès sont là
je me serais je me serais trompé s'il y
avait eu un examen d'histoire ou quoi du
coup droit des deux peut-être qu'à
valider cinq alors maintenant accueille
ses 8
comme vous le savez pourquoi est
également bon je pense que jean
christophe se trouvera tout en confort
ici je pense pas que je le vois aucun
danger
je suis plus que surpris de l'ouverture
de saut parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
est un camion pour préparer très bien
d'avoir ce que vois je
allez il est complètement dominé par par
duda dans cette partie c'est un petit
peu surprenant d'ailleurs parce qu'on
peut penser que noda sera favori en
bullet il était vraiment forts en bulles
est temps que ce soient contrecarrés
acquis nous contre gries tchouk mais
c'est étonnant de voir ceux en
difficulté en cinq minutes
bon après c'est qu'une partie anglade et
quand même non je pense fois que l'on
peut déjà parler des difficultés way
de toute évidence il y près ce pas là
ils pressent pas les documents tableaux
vivants rapide et pratique mais on peut
au moins pas dire qu'il a il ya eu
l'ombre de levante âge que j'essaye de
mettre le chronomètre laddh
ok j'ai enfin réussi à mettre le bon
chrono
à vrai dire je pense que le plus
probable et moi cette partie voix
ce tir mais même par là nul parce que
les noirs n'ont pas de problème mais je
pense pas que le voir son niveau mais
j'ai pas essayé de faire genre cavaliers
bay 6 fixé ici c'est ok il prend avec le
cavalier à 4 pouces et e5 dessin
incroyable s'inquiètent surtout permet à
chaque fois tu commence donc pour
sélénium tu vois avoir des plaines pro
des finesses de blessés qui arrivent
avec chaque coup non je pense pas
qu'elle voit je pense pas l'air par
contre qu'est ce que c'est que ça je te
dire tu as peur pour les noirs wade 6
twh 7.95 et c'est chaud ouais l'opium h
au web non mais c'est vrai c'est hyper
dangereux plus tard tout a été jouée à
l'élite est au smic
ça veut dire que soit je comprend pas
quelque chose soit soit c'est un
problème pour les noirs parce que là
tout va
samba qui suit depuis le plancher il
faudra trouver
ok mais il a peut-être perdu du temps où
aller quand il a fait tour c'est cette
par contre parce qu'il n'est pas allé
prendre le pion c6 finalement il a perdu
un temps et peut-être cinq ans qui va
lui coûter cher parce que regardent
maintenant le roi il contrôle le pion h
et il va avoir le temps de faire cailler
prend des cas donc je pense que oui cela
fait une contre erreur il ya quelques
coups quand il a fait tout rejet s'est
tu regardes 3,6 au lieu d'aller faire
tour à vii direct il a perdu un temps
vous entoure ses sets mais je pense que
ce que surprenant plutôt de la table de
jeu à ce que les deux par rapport à la
responsabilité de la position de 2,8
monde mais c'est hyper compliqué elle a
peut-être un truc lâm f5 pour chasser le
roi est pas le laisser s'approcher mais
du coup il y aura tout reprend ses six
sur échec après ok c'est hyper compliqué
comme position non je n'ai pas dit plus
ou moins tout beau y compris le cas je
pense que pour l'instant ce qui aura
témoigné c'est pas les meilleurs des
parties je pense que lille donne bien le
foot
le dernier dans le dernier vingt tu
penses que c'est dû à la pression début
de match difficultés au démarrage
quelque chose comme ça les deux doivent
rentrer dans le match et pour l'instant
je peux pas dire que c'est ça a été fait
avec le succès ni par l'un ni par
l'autre mais qu'est ce qui se passe la
table deux chiffres la tourbe et six
mois je suis ce que je savais et que
valeo 4 au 6 mai à damerey échec à bord
d'un échec ça je n'essaie pas fait
encore parce que rouaf 7 h 7 b 1 h 8
dames
ok ça faire dame en même temps ça à
faire dame en même temps vous aussi les
besoins vont perdre près le retour au
plus tard on parie que non pas de toute
façon je les commande ira les échecs
sont très dignes et simplement même à
ceux qui croient qu'ils ont trouvé ça
incroyable une nouvelle nul alors que ça
à jouer l'attaqué à fond toute la partie
quoi qu'est ce que c'est que ça quand on
est maudit en ce moment problème le
problème des nuls existait déjà les
pourboires
je vous rappel à l'ordre au début du 20e
siècle et envoûtant de s'articule didier
ce problème la seule chose qui aura un
peu de temps blier un petit pot existe
mais c'est un problème qui peut-être
féroise droit 17 il n'ya pas rouaroua
des quatre accueilli avec trois points
des cinq épreuves 6-3 france et 4 ok ok
à may hamm a terminé avec cette partie
plus intéressante
donc ok ou quatre jours prévient qu'il
ravallec car je me trompe l'oeil
incroyable la hitte fait mentir ouest et
mais il faut pas le répertoire le plus
logique on va dire pour ce match on
aurait pu penser qu'ils jouent de
manière beaucoup plus solide et ils
jouent des positions assez compliqué moi
qu'est ce que vous voulez il ya
tellement bien l'analyser
cette souriante de l'italienne je sais
de quoi je parle parce que j'ai bien
suivi son analyse je pense que il est
analysé ça beaucoup plus loin que tous
les autres il y en a visé jusqu'à
jusqu'à la news n'est est-ce que tu es
heureux vlad de voir que il nous reste
que des joueurs qui prennent la
compétition au sérieux parce qu'on peut
pas dire que ça joue des six petites
lignes aujourd'hui non bon on est
toujours content du pfl bien sûr avec
toujours content de voir les plus forts
vers la fin et je pense que là tout lire
on a toléré toutes les raisons d'espérer
pour le climax mais malheureusement
entre les 4 restants n'ayant sulky
nettement attendez j'ai bien analysé ce
que ce qui aurait sur l'échiquier on
veut pas et je pense que je sais comment
de votre famille pendant les mois à
venir je vous dis est ce qu a attiré l
élément conclusion way sli ou pas te
dire que toi écrite où vous auriez
analyser la même chose que wesley howe
tours fc 8 tours 1
et là je dois me souvenir c'était quoi
les coûts exactement oui une fois une
voie le dire et il va le faire je vous
dirai ce que c'est bien ça se canaliser
la nature revient pour moi c'est nouveau
moi j'aime beaucoup on a les atouts et
voilà je pense que ça mène à l'annulaire
et 10 mois est ce qu'on sait qu'ils les
seconds en 2s l'eso d'ailleurs durant
fut dur à dire en fait moi j'ai pas de
d'information
une sainte - je suppose que ça doit
avoir les amériques quand quelque chose
qu'on chante pointe quelque chose qu'on
peut tête
comment s'appelait petrosyan non pas
contre si elle commence à plérin covial
ou ea coquin donc je pense que d'après
le style de ces partis joie bien cela et
on est d'accord que caruana il avait
aussi dans ses seconds en domingues
dominguez scirea kassim pour nous car
c'est bien sûr et l'autre comment
s'appelle devient aulas commence à peler
ramires alejandro allé ou ce que plutôt
surprenant parce que normalement pour
noter les manches et on prend les
meilleurs des meilleurs et comme quoi le
dos un personnel sont pas riches irina
et ramirez ils paraissent un peu faible
non par rapport aux standards habituels
courants mairesse savoir le poil est au
top niveau et shiva à vrai dire c'est
pas pour être c'est pas pour être si
mobile devrait dire avoir à prendre les
fabrique de saint louis
moi je connaissais ce que je la joue en
bits contre lui sur internet
oui oui il existait déjà avant que tous
les joueurs sur le terrain avec des
succès d'ailleurs ah ouais ce qui est
inquiétant surtout en rapide ok écouté
mon cher ami un peu déjà témoigné que
[Musique]
jean-christophe la réal un petit mot sur
l'ouverture que les noirs sont
parfaitement bien près de tout moi bien
je pense pas que millions mais pas du
tout moins bien et ça montre pour
l'instant une préparation assez minable
avec les banques parce que sauce il joue
sa ligne fétiche valait une fiche depuis
un certain temps et donc quand même il
faut terminer au préparé mais c'est le
problème
le premier incarne le diplomate est un
de ceux qui a vient d'arriver dans
l'élite
c'est que ils sont doux tout au début où
il leur manque que et leurs marques de
lait finesse de la préparation
voilà excusez moi moi il fallait être
préparé mon salaire parce que par
exemple moi j'ai un round 3 jouera sans
briller à la fin de l'été j'ai regardé
ce qui est du coup est ce qu'un joueur
du niveau de duda il a déjà un second
temps ou pas williams you mais le
problème c'est pas ça le problème le
cerf il ya beaucoup de gens qui peuvent
t'aider
hoyo de la préparation mais ya pas
beaucoup de gens qui pouvaient très bien
parce que je pense que pas pour me
vanter moins au niveau d'eau au niveau
créatif et il ya très peu de gens qui
trouvent
c'est dire qu'ils sont vraiment
productif mais par exemple imaginons tu
vois je suis duda on imagine que je suis
tout ça et je veux prendre un second
temps de haut niveau donc un second
temps de haut niveau dans 90% des cas où
95% j'imagine que c'est un second temps
qui est déjà occupé mais la plupart
doivent être occupés quand même non
l'erc le poids mais pas tous non
tous par exemple riante et en ukraine
point de jeunes restent très
opérationnelle est libre comme je sais
pas qu'on parle enfin exemple mais ces
propos mais ce que je sais prenons mario
ce n'est pas à prix d'or par quelqu'un
donc je pense qu il faut pas il faut pas
il faut pas surestimer le problème et je
pense qu un point d très fort garnett
qui centrait tout à fait mais du coup
comment tu fais quand tu vas prendre un
second non tu n'appelles et tu lui dis
est ce que tu peux me seconde et de
beechwood et tu la payes tu lui dis que
tu adores son style et il dit est ce
qu'il a fait c'était le cas quand
j'étais déjà pour la première fois
contre kramnik faire l'écho 2004 il m'a
appelé justin madier ce sens m'intéresse
je te dis donc t'as juste taper sur ton
téléphone perso et à 10,5 vlad comment
ça va il a trouvé ça très vite avec les
dom un loisir un copain et je pense qu'à
l'époque que ceux qui ont ce que les
réunionnais à choisir ma candidature ce
que c'est que à l'époque que je peux
considérer qu'on croit un petit peu un
pti chronique n'est plus qu'a vécu très
longtemps à l'époque je te comprends que
c'est et on s'est dit que ça allait se
surmotiver conquois il n'a pas fois nous
chercher
extra motivation on apprend de celle qui
joue déjà
ouais en fait ça fait très longtemps que
j'adore comment bouadi leurs jours
surtout maintenant l époque il est vrai
souvent ce match c'est le match que
l'écho avait perdu à la dernière ronde
et le fameux à la dernière partie il n'a
pas quinze fois il n'a pas perdu sa fait
match nul
comment dire matt et moi on a eu
l'impression de calexium avec une pac
asus avait fait du bon du coup cette
partie vadis passe pas grand-chose grand
chose pour le moment pas grand chose
mais la doda vial de me surprendre
beaucoup parce que même si tours à dos
et un bon cours normalement afpa de thé
les coudes et les cadences rapides parce
qu'on n'a pas la tour
c'est très dangereux parce que sinon un
qui sait que c'est c'est un peu si
jamais l'oublier mais regarde il est
très mal autant il reste 23 secondes
bon je parie en fait les maintenant dans
le judo dans les journaux
jean-christophe je pense qu'ils en
tirent un peu comment dire un petit
moyen 2 faiblit pas les plus grands les
premières c'est bien sûr la préparation
des ruptures et la deuxième c'est bien
les maîtrises de finale parce que je
pense que le plus probablement elle va
partir de là il montre qu'il est pas
tout à fait à l'aise quand même je suis
pas très impressionnant parcours quand
il joue il est maintenant et je pense
que s'il continue de l'aimer manière il
est très probable ça se voit que il est
pas dans son élément dans son sixième
élément non il a du mal à placer les
pièces et on sent que maintenant c'est
wesley qui a tout le jeu la tour sur b3
allait super bien placé elle coupe le
roi pas au cas où il ya un échange là on
va le voir maintenant le roi il peut
plus monter le pion b2 reste en prise à
bail va même sur votre tête avec un pion
- même si on n'est pas obligé
rendre le plus positif et roanne g63 f5
date peut-être pour monter droits dans
tous les cas c'est très désagréable et
qui apprend le plus haut si on prend le
cas et je dois vous dire comme sur mon
chronique par exemple ouais c'est sûr
c'est un génie des finales où il ya un
peu mieux
donc là maintenant sur wave 4 3 3 car
bien sûr bon c'est déjà un gros souci
parce que c'est un de plus tu penses que
c'est encore nulle théorique avec un jeu
parfait pour les blancs où on est déjà
dans la zone où ces perdants
je sais pas je peux pas dire maintenant
comme ça je pense que c'est quand même
plus proche
c'est quand même plus proche de la terre
que dans certains dom
le cavalier pour le cavaliere fois ok
mais là est ce que tu vas pas transposer
ça ça s'est il veut dire que va
sacrifier la tour qui va envoyer les
pions et que ça va gagner un bon match
parce que le proche vrai que si on prend
de ckac et pourquoi il a pris prise g4
voit bouger les 3 6 6 1 et peut-être il
pouvait faire échec échec je sais pas je
pense que je suis jeune mais déjà la
fois dans les connaissances théoriques
pour doter le final mais je vais
toujours peur de rentrer ses malheurs si
j'ai par contre les ici maintenance je
pense que tout est complètement clair je
pense que il ya pas photo il va faire
froid f3c huit dames prise prise g2 skt
sûr que c'est nul ça j'ai 2 bras 2 6
soit tout à l'heure j'étais sûr
maintenant je le suis plus haut mais je
pense que c'est plutôt nous qui sommes
le 4 juin mais autant prêt un vote en
prêt plus inquiets qu'à l'heure où tu as
plate c'est incroyable bon je pense
qu'après deux parties un peu déjà dire
qu'ils font
ouais c'est ça pourquoi moi j'adore
succession qui est favori
de toute évidence les eaux favorise ce
genre est redoutable parce que en
surtemps mal de l'ouverture quand même
elle s'est fait refaire il a quand même
été en difficulté deux fois d'affilée
vlad
alors ce n'est pas parce que il était
dans la difficulté dès l'ouverture mais
une fois ce jeu c'est de jouer
il semble donc dû penser à faire un peu
le même scénario que contre great choqué
car yakine c'est à dire que plus le
match va continuer - il va y avoir de
temps à la pendule plus duda va sortir
ses griffes
c'est bien ça c'est que je pense
maintenant d'ailleurs après le huitième
cour f4 c'est intéressant est ce que
jean christophe va trouver le meilleur
coup ici et là bas parce que je pense
après 4 heures sous symbian os oui mais
tu connais où tu penses c'est le kansas
depuis les jeunesses par coup en cavale
et c6 dalle de 2,5 et leurs fesses à
matemale ok si ces joies vos les cimes
je pense que sans qu'avant c'était plus
précis qu'est ce que vous voulez lire
les gens n'ont pas de
des moyens manquent en fait non pas des
mêmes millions de connaissances que nous
et heureusement parce que sinon ça fait
peur toyota fait part c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont le font ce qu'ils savent -
où elle est avec ma présence je pense
qu'on est arrivé dans la position du
groupe rishi content kasparov d'user 80
82 et c'est que c'est déjà très bien
pour les noirs parce que parce que
sicoval et de 3,6 que les trois collèges
créateur je pense que ça a été de la
partie sicoval et le 5-fu 5 heures f24
de saint que les noirs sont bien nouveau
donc mais comment comment tu connais
tout ça mais comment c'est possible
c'est même pas ton répertoire tu joues
pas sa voix est écoutée réagir je viens
aux check points mais qu'est-ce que vous
et les échecs et toute ma vie c'est ce
feuilleton normal que je connais tous
parce que c'est pour les autres
pour les autres le monde étrangers
commencent par le fait de rentrer aux
échecs pour moi le monde des trajets
comme ans de partir il ya pour moi ou
comme un seul univers étrange quand tu
sors d échec
je suppose après landreau comme libre 4e
volet de 14,8 à et que plusieurs de
dépôts y compris toutes et tous voient
donc je joue bien le noir
et quand les boukakes ya un faux dossier
ce qui existe et là je parle je parle
beaucoup de couleurs fondues 6 d'un v6
dans ce cas il ya une question
intéressante dans le chatt vlad et on
peut on peut y revenir après en mais
cela pose déjà c'est honteux demande
quel
quel est le niveau raybaud by fischer
s'il était à à son meilleur niveau
aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est reda main pour tout
le monde je pense que les reer 2009 où
tu penses que c'est vraiment le joueur
le plus doué de l'histoire des échecs
ok il ya besoin de joueurs doués
pendant toute l'histoire de chèques
l'histoire de check up bourré d des
personnages véhicules loués et il y
avait très peu de jeu de jeu j ai moi je
peux citer que trois noms mais jorge
ignore je vais dire toujours et je
coordonne avec des thèmes je vais le
répéter alors je pense qu'il ya vécu
autrefois joueur génial c'est donc notre
compatriote andré laur puis pour mon
fils et gamme bogut touché avec le sont
d'autres on va y revenir après la partie
de sa blague parce que j'aurai des
questions à se poser pas parce qu'on a
qu'on éclaircisse certains points du
coup qu'est ce que tu penses l'idée
surtout condé si ces prises prise c'est
ce que je suis en train de bouger prise
prise prise ça et ça mais c'était un peu
triste non
je dois réfléchir un petit que je dois
réfléchir un peu pour moi c'est bizarre
ce qu'il fait mais peut-être cette
fois-ci mois les plus tôt le problème
c'est juste que si les noirs font en
cours comment il dit à neutre
les noirs n'ont pas résolu encore le
problème comment est-ce que des lois
avant de réagir sur les attaques du viol
des six
merci de toute évidence je vais pas je
connais 5 parce que comment ils étaient
quatre au maximum
comment est ce que je veux réagir parce
que tu heureux vite résolu au palio
proviennent d'une manière décisive mais
c'est complètement mêler les pinceaux
dans avec les noirs parce qu'il attend
du retard des cavaliers b4 maintenant il
se prend foulée 5 qui attaquent la tour
voilà mon cher ami vous savez très bien
que très souvent j'ai résonnent les ados
nouveau jury zone
la troisième partie ce n'est que le
début de la domination de
jean-christophe que je pense que comment
dire la troisième partie samatan mais là
il est payant tracé maggiori
jean-christophe non je vais dire que le
réel
jean-christophe ishow avec les noix non
non non non
là je dois revenir à un moment il se
trompe et il joue pas très bien
excusez moi excusez moi s'il vous plaît
non mais ça arrive t'inquiète pas je
pensais qu'il joue avec les bois bonjour
jean paul commandé le jeu sage parce que
là il a menti et de la culture générale
ici c'est bien ce que je disais donc
jean christophe il est en train de se
viander mais je pense que c'est les
dames donc on peut dire que tu avais tu
as attention enfin branche nord je pense
que moi tu marques tu fous je craque
donc
faussé d'avancé comme si elles
investissent sophos est enlevée au moins
pour réfléchir et je pense qu'ils vont
donc tu n'avais pas raison donc je me
suis trompé excusez moi je me suis
trompé de la couleur des pièces des
adversaires qui est leur honte
excusez moi je sais que je vais essayer
de me corriger
pendant les parties non mais c'est pas
grave
d'un autre côté c'est arrivé que que
pendant 30 secondes à tiens regarde
regarde regarde ce qui fait c'est très
bien joué dans près d'un point de vue
pratique il a envoyé la d'américains
regardent mais c'est là qu'il est fort
wesley duda maintenant moi aussi je me
trompe mais c'est pas mal joué là ce
qu'il a fait non de prendre à sa charge
les relations de l'opposition l'objectif
objectivement non mais comme contre
comme comme contre gries juke est contre
[Musique]
car yakine dans les positions perdues il
trouve des ressources pratiques
bah c'est pour ça que le yoga c'est pour
ça que les les
c'est génial pour moi les fantastiques
se met le jeu je l'avais depuis
plusieurs années déjà
parce que c'est un phénomène plus ou
moins deux échecs polonais mais s'il
continue ou se préparer de la même
manière qu'ils ont bêtement
malheureusement va passer à temps
général du jura a ajouté un jeu me
rajouter modérateur histoire qu'on ait
plus de problème là tu parce qu'on se
faisait trop les sur le chat est
j'avais pas le bon ordinateur pour
ralala les gens sont tellement pénible
attends attends tu entends
ok c'est nickel c'est bon on est bons
glad pardon excusez moi de de t'avoir
interview h4 vianne docteur jouais je
pense que ça reste toujours très
désagréable parce que six cavaliers 4 il
y à fond de 7,6 g regarnir précisément
jeu 513
je pense que ce doit être objective moi
c'est plus mon futur
oui il faut montrer les précisions
jusqu'au bout non mais tu vas voir tu y
vas essayer de trouver un truc mais qui
est ce que possible de trouver après fou
de cette épave les deux tours il ya le
cavalier qui tombe pour ses sets et adam
huit tours h1 ou d'un v8 fou pranger
quatre mois hier et à tous qu'il tombe
sauf si je vois pas un coup de génie et
à tous du temps doux bruit te sais quoi
les défauts j'ai quatre cols et une fois
qu on ne peut pas croire ça au pire des
cas aucune beckham que je d'un mois
trois mois je pense pas que ça je pense
que j'insiste c'est les réactions de le
pelouse les plus faciles jeu 6 avec
l'hébergeur fou 6 enfin je pense que
c'est un petit peu de gens qui n'ont pas
pourquoi fab et par là les femmes sera
là demain et après-demain et six femmes
a pas fait les vidéos pendant ce
championnat du monde et qui n'est pas
souvent là c'est que fab est souvent
absent soit en tournoi soit soit là il y
avait d'autres obligations
mais ça vous aime pas ma présence
thacker parfois bukavu oui les bords
mais c'est juste que suivant souvent
plata des gens qui sont arrivés sur la
chaîne tci ya pas très longtemps
il ya un an ou deux ans ou deux ans et
demi mais en fait ça par coeur la chaîne
vitry mal existe depuis six ans et que
et que voilà il ya quatre ans où j'ai
fait seul après toi tu as fait un petit
peu fait beaucoup de vidéo aussi avec
fab
mais il ya un peu de tout le monde quoi
oui oui je sais que tu as beaucoup du
succès continu de la manière comme ça
qui va faire beaucoup plus pour les
échecs que n'importe quelle fédération
[Musique]
du coup la non retourne dans la même
ouverture
oui mais à vrai dire je comprends pas le
choix de dos dames de toute évidence il
n'est pas préparé à ce qu'ils ont dû
attendre dans cette ouverture là donc le
point avec des cinq très tôt et donc on
va dire je critique très sévèrement à
cinq opérations d'air parce que même moi
je connais de quoi sauter mais tu penses
que tu es en train de changer ton avis
et te dire que c'est plutôt ce qui
favorise toujours pas toujours pas
toujours pas tout simplement parce qu'
il existe la préparation du minable où
les pressions excellente duda 1 vient
d'arriver d'alizée chiens d'élite donc
bien sûr le comprends pas encore de quoi
il s'agit mais il existe aussi comment
s'appellent les esprits et les corps on
les lui les a et les cocos une excuse
moi mais c'est pas tout à fait wesley
wesley est neuve give up saw c'est
fantastique ce rugby never give up alors
que le mec n'a jamais vraiment essayé
maintenant je laisse expliqué c'est toi
qui est à berlin
ok à partie
deux phases près à partir de 5e ou 6e
partir tu saurais témoigne dans le
tournoi et les vrais gens là -2 et tout
est à vendre et donc normalement il doit
jouer un tout près n'importe quel parti
de très bas donc il vient de jouer à
lyon puis alexander zschokke alexander
s'attendait à une grosse bagarre
moi je dis non au nom du respect à nos
pages c'est ce qui va arriver et donc
ils jouaient super à la lecture entre
donc dans 28 30 ou aussi nul de ger et
pendant leur conférence de presse les
journalistes de man ouest qui est ce que
vous voulez faire pour le reste du
tournoi
et cette partie là il répondu à m et
vous dis bah c'est difficile que je vois
nos jambes et bien sûr il y aurait ceux
des partis avec une doivent elles et
continuer de ce moment c'est un
synthétique soir dit il sera donc ses
divisions locales - avec christian
caleca michael hüther wesley mais je
pense qu'il peut juste pas faire
autrement non non mais c'est son style s
sont logiques et il joue de manière
attentif il s'est commencé après les
russes s'appellent de jouer avec le
numéro deux et je pense que peut-être ça
se comprend français unique avec nous
que de jouer avec les avec le frein à
main on dire en français oui tu série
haut commandement français mais avec le
frein à main
il prend jamais trop de risques ou
presque
donc bien sûr c'est très bien pour les
résultats à long terme mais bien sûr
avec ça c'est pas facile de devenir
devenir les hôtes du mondial aux idoles
des cas du coup je veux pas critiquer
bien sûr parce que
je jouais plus moindre émoi hier donc
c'est pas moi qui va critiquer mais
c'est que ces poids sur l'échiquier
c'est intéressant d'ailleurs parce que
le conflit bien établies ce qu'on voit
maintenant après tout à 1 801 présent en
conflit intéressant à lire les boys puis
le jeudi 4 4 2 sans les voir que je
collectionne et total sera intéressant à
chaque fois et je pense que les noirs
doivent être bien mais je sais pas moi
perso je rêve plus d'offres s'il était
de jouer à cuba ouais j'aime bien moi le
fou en c1 qui a réussi à revenir les
tours qui sont passés le fond b3 qui
attaquent le cavalier le roi suite qui
peut peut-être un jour avoir des
problèmes sur la colonne h
je suis d'accord avec toi blatt c'est
plus facile à jouer avec les blancs
ouais ce jusqu à chaque fois j'ai
toujours préféré le jeu contre l'ess
l'intrus l'infrastructure qui refleurit
et c'est le gallo cas de loire cette
position parce que malgré les six buts
et comment s'appellent les visibles il
ya pas mal de casseroles et y compris
leur aura donc pour moi ça aurait été
plus facile de jouer avec le mans - ici
il est probable qu'il le doit
il n'ya pas cavalier pour un f5 la
longue épreuve 5 d'alger si c'est ça
l'idée je suis moi je suis pas sûre que
celle d'angers 4 à 5 par exemple
ok mais puis on comprend qu'il est
simple ok mais ces choix là confie -
what may day les situations dans deux
retraités parfois je vois plus que non
ils ont fait bienvenue à 5 david katz et
la partie blad s'il n'a pas les ados
alors les problèmes
qui savait reese r déjà je parle moi de
partir du fou et c'est parce que je
pense pas que de tels coups kung fu 1,7
les retraites sur la position précise à
bastian adapter le souverain à cause de
ça mais tu sais qui en plus je suis
doublement heureux de ce retour de de
duda qui va probablement gagner cette
partie je l'espère parce que ce sera mon
coéquipier cette année pas je vais
mettre son manager pour la prophétie se
félicite avec ce feu là et je te
félicite avec ce qu'on appelle un très
bon investissement
est ce que ça te motive pour venir jouer
avec nous cette année
ou pas si je joue quoi je joue quoi tu
veux dire si tu joues nulle part tu
joues pas avec nous non plus ben quand
j'expliquais mille fois j'ai trop la
honte de jouer moi elsie je sais que je
veux je te le temps mais c'est pas une
mauvaise décision
enfin d'agritel surtout m'a dit que je
suis trop rachat pour moi - oui mais je
ne trouve pas si sévère en français oui
se joue ce que je préfère de rester sur
mon banc que juin
du coup là pour gagner cette finale on
fait quoi on fait tourner eu un fou g3
on attaque la faiblesse le pion isolés
on le gagne on gagne la finale mais il
faut quand même faire gaffe aux pions
détroit qui arrivait pour gagner rien
faire du tout parce que les semaines se
gagne avec les éléments dernière avec
les mains pour pour toi blâmer pour pour
des joueurs d'un niveau on va dire 2000
eux-mêmes 1800 milles 6 ans et pas
forcément évident à gagner ça tombait
donc lâché trois attaques nocturnes
5 si les noirs attaque le pion de trois
ans le défendent avec force et 4 et le
foot 5 mai c'est ce n'est qu on ne
saurait que le travail pour les manches
oui mais j'ai hâte imagine fin pour toi
c'est facile à voir mais pour un joueur
comme moi de voir fou j'ai trois fous b3
fous ces quatre fous des cinq pour eux 3
to run c'est pas si simple
je comprends très bien qu'elle vienne
que je dois être accessible pour le
spectateur et je sais très bien que
contre moi tu aurais gagné salle
pas de chance qui me connaît trop bien
je te connais trop bien et tu te tais
référé tout ça de manière exemplaire
mais note une dernière fois dans un café
sur grasse et valence j'aime bien ce
type boeing ainsi témoigner de ma
technique légendaire mais qu'est-ce que
je peux faire sérieux tu es devenu
beaucoup plus fort que revoir et non
mais c'est vrai que c'est un problème
oui maintenant
donc il faut certes hockey d'options de
plus qui est ce qu'ils ont volé
encore faux seins des cadeaux je croise
simple enfin il ya pas mal de
possibilités différentes mais je pense
que celle qu'ils je viens de citer c'est
ok y'a pas photo bien sûr cette finale
avec un pion de plus ce conflit avec
d'autres
tu peux aussi faire des quatre tours
cette foule cinq toilettes est passé
d'autres terrains que tu peux tu peux
être puriste et tu peux être simpliste
et youtube est heureux je m'en foutiste
meilleur c'est bien mais tu peux faire
tout ce que tivio parce que google avec
les c4 est un peu bizarre non quand même
pas
moi je leur ai jamais fait mais juste un
peu tu te pose des problèmes pour rien
en fait je joue un truc très tactique
alors que capello commission sam
problème avec une audace qui elle est
très bien pour un joueur comment dire
bonjour concrètement à coup après
l'autre ou encore le top contre l'autre
donc construit ce n'est pas si facile
parce qu'il pose des problèmes à chaque
fois elle pose des problèmes ouais c'est
pas pour ici parce que le problème c'est
pas youtube
le problème c'est pas d'audio je prends
les on n'aime pas ça le premier c'est
que le fou noir et pas si fort pour le
reste ce qui est étrange c'est qu'il a
il a plus que 20 secondes déjà aidé un
truc très facile où ils pouvaient
pousser les pions mécaniquement placer
ses tours il est rentré dans un truc
tactique où il est possible de faire une
erreur à tout moment non d'autant que
magna ok mais regarde il va déjà père
d'un pion 6,6 et roy qui peuvent se
permettre un coup kung fu de 4
qu'est ce que c'est que ça vanne auquel
je m attends sur le 7e crs toujours
gagner mais bien sûr il est bien
compliqué la tâche mais l'auto 3 hier je
suppose que ça reste toujours gagnant
malgré les pics qui lui a dit non mais
c'est un vrai problème pour lui les
finales quand même ah tiens oui il s'est
mis à l'attaqué directe sur nous on voit
et ce qu'on voit c'est intéressant parce
qu'il veut dire que le plus on arrive
sur quatre avec les succès et c'est
intéressant mais que terrain et les
parties en cause non mais il va perdre
il a plus de temps blâme lundi la plus
de temps s'il est le temps alors il va
succéder
ok mais son nom selon lui n'a plus de
temps plus personne n'a de temps vlad
yakin dc cointe qui reste à la main au
quai cette position là je sais pas
quelle est l'évolution exact ouais moi
je les dis que c'est plutôt non mais
c'est quelque chose de pas avoir gagné
ça mais comme je prédis bien avant les
bois et métallique sont allés perdre
[Musique]
oui ok mais il a il a raté là ce n'est
que le début de ce que revoir se
produire mais c'est tout d'anna qui a
raté valdes a pu encore qui a raté de
toute manière sur 21
[Rires]
tu viens de te rendre compte que tu
avais encore renverser les couleurs des
versions de duda pas pourquoi il se
vante encore visiblement tout le monde
est mort de rire dans le tchad la ddt
question vaut lire je viens de terminer
de commenter allemagne chic je
commandais programme trois noms mais en
fait c'est ce que t'as pas un tape à
l'oeil en fait on change de côté à
chaque fois est à l'impression que les
adversaires je comprends pourquoi tu te
trompes en fait qu'est-ce que tu pas
inscrire de cette semaine je pense que
c'est égal je serai jouer avec les noirs
ne s'est jamais pensé exactement à la
même chose et pourtant les ordinateurs
dom
avantage un avantage assez clair aux
blancs ouais tu fais à chaque fois
c'était un talent show pour moi parce
que j'aimerais plus croire à ça mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez je regarde
d'ordinateur en ordinateur je sais que
son évolution si j'allais plus à 14
c'est incroyable ça c'est incroyable
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jeanmaire comédien j'ai jamais
vraiment compris la force de la manière
du gâteau c'est le troisième qui ne peut
pas de 3,8 à 12,23 quelque chose comme
ça d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je me
suis trompé sur l'évolution de la police
ou pas d'accord je me trompe pas c'est
bien les ordinateurs qui cette fois je
dois par coup en terre jeu de tête 5
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi
mais c'est incroyable il sait pas jouer
les huées les fumeurs sur power
pourquoi c'est vraiment pas bon f5 ouais
ça partira pas cette position juste
il en avait juste besoin de ce coup
l'heure il rejoint d'autres coûts et à 5
c pas pour ici
carson web de moins bouger du que match
mais du coup h 5 à 5 c'est vrai qu'il a
du mal à réaliser l'harmonie
je sais que c'est incroyable avec avis
que jean-christian ce qu'une jolie
courmont voyait tri quelques c'est quoi
ça veut dire beaucoup d'ailleurs sur ces
échecs lui dire qu'il comprend l'impasse
au public et qu'on prend mon poing que
d'aller fumer
il est tout il est au des raisons tu
pense qu'il peut être champion du monde
un jour 12 à alon mais sans aucune
chance perso je rate d'ailleurs je sais
même pas qui peut devenir champion du
monde
par rapport à ma muse malheureusement
tout le monde donc je vois moins pas
aucun danger à vie ils n'auraient pu
avoir un danger de la part de martigné
aussi il aurait eu ou de soutien de la
part des fédérations
[Musique]
mais il n'a pas il n'a pas le soutien de
la fédération artemiev au cube au camp
tout simplement parce que pour en avoir
réussi il faut être de moscou de saint
pétersbourg et pour les provinciales
c'est toujours dur pendant l'union
soviétique pendant les russies en
dépendent
c'est toujours une histoire que d'aller
beaucoup pour avoir quoi que ce soit si
ce n'est pas de
les deux femmes il ya qu'eux car yakine
qui a réussi à avoir de l'aide en étant
ni moscovite ni péters bourgeois je sais
pas comment ni en force et 5 petit
bourgeois centenaire et les rues
beaucoup de la chance
tout simplement parce que il est venu en
russie exactement au bon moment car g
nique puis radio sa couronne compte donc
c'était quoi l'histoire l'histoire de
retourner la couronne en russie c'est
devenu comme quoi les questions de
l'état russe et c'est en ce moment mais
qu'il est apparu en russie et donc si
que il a obtenu en tant que des
conditions en russie c'était parce que
tout de suite ayant obtenu tous lire
pour le second dame tous les pouvoirs
pour son relogement à tous les pour quoi
que ce soit et personne n'a jamais eu un
tel luxe avant de mourir donc ouais il
faut il a fallu été rejoint sur scène il
a fallu tombée au bon être au bon
endroit au bon moment
oui mais par contre je dois dire que
c'est un terrain
j'ai par exemple quand je dis qu'il
était champion parce que les grands
champions sont toujours chasse oui dans
tous les sports d'ailleurs dans l'auto
d'espoir et à chaque fois que analyse
l'histoire dont n'importe qui est
dangereux de quoi que ce soit c'est
toujours l'histoire de la chance je n'ai
pas mal
c'est ce qu'il faut pour être champion
peut faire la différence peut être un
moment donné mais comme ce match contre
car celle d'hier 10 m2 il ya deux ans
montrent pas que ça du coup la
différence et si ça marche ici ma c'est
une question qui doit être posée
à vrai dire je tends compris pourquoi
est-ce que le doigt le curleur moi non
plus mais peut-être comment fermer la
tour ils vont gagner
ces 6 ouais si dangereux après pouvoir
de trois mois
c'est tour décide quelque chose comme ça
c'est très dangereux
donc je pense pas qu'il y avait besoin
de ça mais qui est ce que je comprend
peut-être je vois pas quelque chose me
tour des clcc menace en avoir deux trois
voire quatre autour des six essais les
plus hauts la rixe ont besoin mais après
avoir laissé fait comment nato est
enfermé vad
je sais mais je donne c'est que les
filles et les qualités et qui bougeait
et voilà qu'ils me tuent mais tatouant
des mythes oui je pensais pas à ce
retour sur scène j'ai passé sur le tour
des sites pour faire plus d ok je pense
que ce serait plus intéressant parce que
maintenant il ya sur les droits ne rêve
pas que nos fermiers les après tour des
six jeux intéressants
tu voulais avoir le pion mais tu vas
avoir trois pions passé bas parce que
dans ces cas là ici et tous méritent la
taurine vocable par exemple en que
joueur fou et 6 à 3 pts 4 hour wayne
hélas déjà cinq top 5 tours 5
à voir à tourbes 4 tours 5 lorsque pas
trop mais bon
j'essaie de faire semblant que oui quoi
paga peut être dérogé joly dit que des
conneries
non mais c'est juste que j'ai pas réussi
à suivre mais là je vois pas comment les
blancs les blancs peuvent plus gagner là
déjà c'est fini mais est ce que les
noirs peuvent avoir un plan l'histoire
de l'histoire goto reprendre ce s'était
pas tomber si c'est l'histoire
d'accorder que tout ce qu elle peut
espérer qu'ils offraient news moi je
pense que non elle ne peut pas passer
derrière sur tour des cinq lie à b4 ont
frappé cinq essais les blancs qui vont
gagner et donc il va faire prise prisé
tour bessette est nul toi l effort faut
continuer
non c'est ça ça va faire nul donc du
coup là cette partie là vlad qui avait
les blancs j'ai pas le l'approchent
d'alléger du retour de dubaï pour cette
partie je suis toujours pour oui je
pense toujours que les favoris way pour
la fin sa préparation je les trouve
juste à l'est elles étaient moins bien
donc dé la finale en fait qu'ils n'ont
pas faim qui paraissait égal si on ne
connaissait pas l'évaluation de leurs 10
mai qui était mieux pour les blancs et
saouasiah le savait mais après tout
c'est quoi cette fois outre cette
progression peter citoyens qui vont
expliquer mais oui six mois ferme - n'a
rien donné
pour l'instant tout juste si koné plus
je regarde attias il tente
kim a raison je veux parce que la série
ce qui d'ailleurs moi je vais pas moi je
n'ai pas osé
moi non plus fou cette food & cie ce qui
est mieux faire tour à 4 mais ouais ok
c'est 5 sap à la tête d'un truc bien
pour les blancs ça ok mais comment
est-ce que les banques russes qui est
ici bonjour je ne pense pas que c'est
possible
ok peut-être elle s'est dit que ce n'est
qu'une autre manière autonome
qu'est ce qui peut faire avec les noirs
pour gagner
nous ne casse pas la tête kevin je pense
pas qu'il y aurait si tu pense qu'il va
même pas essayé ok il a joué tout ça
mais alors ok je peux jouer 3 500 kwh
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose à part
d'auto à rob 4 il ya je le pense quoi
qui fait ici de faire tourner bien mais
il va refaire voir ces 5
je dois vous dire que j'ai 2 comment
dire jeux d'eau contemplation de ma vie
si lyon doit donner à bouffer à l'air
d'être un bon ce que vous allez vous
faire beaucoup plus si les positions à
l'est avec un véhicule et laborde si ça
marche que pour la bouffe et les parties
d'échecs ou pour le reste aussi
wikio pour les choses personnelles aussi
donc ok comportiez intrants pour skill
convard et dix personnes
ii ya deux ans et ceux qui jouent la
bonne variante avec gf moi qui
flatteront postiers avec les blancs
c'est très désagréable ça pour les
blancs bah je sais ce juste parce que ça
et on n'aime pas le truc c'est dans des
cartes ou égaliser compris dépensé 4 et
quand il s'est si souvent aussi
d'ailleurs dans bay 5 heures et surtout
d'air hier plutôt qu'un petit mois
prière lui très important qu'elle
pouvait à ses moyens que 15 ans d'un v6
avec l'idée qu'on va laisser croire
nombre d'eux quand on est de 5 et
maintenant le couple est fou ça on tape
sur les 15 f1 et si donc comment les
sept rois de 8 colère 8
ça marche pas parce que je pense le bon
coup
faux sur d'amsterdam c3 dans ce 3 et
roidot et je pense que les noirs pour
vous bien sûr faire les repetto de suite
mais les noirs peuvent bel ici je me
reconnais plus de quelle manière quoi
laisser ce que l'étoile a pour l'instant
je vois pas en jeu séculaire donc est
bon c'est pas on va entendre à la partie
voilà donc il faut insister et ses
droits ok corral et c'est ce qui est
surprenant donc les deux canards
visiblement moins que moi c'est puisque
peu de terreau n'est pas chacun pense
que c'est le cas de tout le monde donc
le 5 sa joie pour la première fois c'est
des cons les d4 quand l'étoile nombre ou
se décoller des cadres que le jeu de jeu
plus quoi mois d'août au poignard et
varane se décoller décalage ce qu'est ce
que la chose mais c'est assez dégueu à
jouer ça pour les blancs en fait c'est
vraiment dur à jouer avec les bars mais
le problème c'est que comment dire il
joue son match avec les banques en
thaïlande des jeux en ligne ont su parer
aux mots mais il a fallu aux gammes à
faire quelques efforts avant visiblement
avec rien dans ses bagages
mais il est venu équipage 8 l'un
complètement complètement aucunement
mais à vrai dire j'aime pas ça parce que
ça monte la moindre de responsabilité
sans montre enfin j'veux pas cette
approche-là posco si vous voyez je suis
plus ou moins de l'ancienne école je
pense qu il faut quand même se préparer
mais la mer est là qu il a quand même
réussi à battre comme ça et gris tout
écart yakine ce qui est vraiment
impressionnant gladin madame ça va être
plus dur aujourd'hui parce que le tarif
est de johan à quoi s'attend il y aura
plus l'effet de surprise pour l'autre
c'est déjà de quoi s'attendait à un
autre c'est déjà que les lectures sais
pas d'où dame est
au milieu du jour où et une fois c'est
compliqué c'est il est bien présent
donc il peut plus chaque et avec ce
niveau
après cela mais pour la fin de ce que je
vois sur l'échiquier
à vrai dire je vois pour la première
fois il est très dur pour moi de bonus
d'après un curieux jeu ridicule
savoir parler droit qu'est ce que c'est
elle doit toutefois soin que moi j'en ai
déjà vu des pires matos le pire coup à
jouer avec moi bien sûr
en fait quand je joue la trompe offs qui
est qu'un mec joue cette variante la
partie d'après je joue plus la troupe au
ski non mais je trouve cette langue
fleurie tapas la paire de fous les prix
ont doublé c'est pas un problème parce
qu'ils prennent le centre et même les
noirs te font rock et maître laurent a
chuté de toute façon tu peux pas
l'attaquer juge je comprends pas
l'intérêt pour les blancs de jouer ça
fait c j'ai juste l'impression d'être
moins bien sans raison ok oui il répète
la moindre ouverture qu'elle a révélé
aux chiens et chiots que tiens regarde
ça j'ai pas trop compris mais peut-être
je le saurai si oui est ce making-of
non mais ça c'est quand même un peu
infantile non je vois que raison de jo
jo même pas moins pas l'aider parce que
faux seins car il fait le fou ce départ
c'est aussi six gendarmes arrivent sur
https burgondes mais si l'on est ce que
tu penses que j'ai si bien fait de le
recruter finalement ou est ce que tu
penses que depuis que je les recruter il
a bien baissé
tard bien rire se tenait à aller sous
condition à laquelle tu utilises tu es
type intel donald aux nationaux pour me
payer que j'aurais propre à chaque fois
que je le paye lui et toi pour le
préparer quoi ça va vous coûter très
cher je le sais que nos moments en tant
qu' en tant que dirigeant je sais que
nos moments encore m peut-être que tu y
as we à moi je paye aussi cornette
en fait je paye tout le monde et si
jamais tu pouvais son ex-compatriote
fois bien aussi je suis ruinée vlad je
suis ruinée non mais attends il ya
peut-être gagner quand même un qui sait
y'a même pas d'aider leur ai même pas de
détours je crois que oui à nos pâturages
suite fait et afin d'aider les tutoriaux
huit tarifs 5 arif je vois pas trop
donné le jeu n'a pas l'ombre d'une
menace et tu sais que c'est pourquoi
parce qu'il y en a pas attends un peu
peut-être faire un truc genre tour des
trois avec l'idée de faire tout reprend
j'essaie trois projets cet objet 3 et /
ou h7 cavalli g5
mais ok sur tour des 3 il y aura juste
tour 8 peut-être vrai mais ok tour 8
dans le premier set
nantes c'est surfait retour des 3 mai
après tour c'est 8
trop d 3 mai 9 h 3e set il prépare tour
des 3 ou et je pense que tout de suite
devrait être le cours dont ces deux
interviews et à propos de maintenant je
sais parle déjà c'est intéressant qu'est
ce que les préparer sur une sangle je
suppose que ce doit être quelque chose
comme un danger d'un huissier sturgeon 8
et 15 59 donc dalo 8 c'est bien sûr une
bonne technique parce que tu repars f5
être pas 0,5
aussi et comme il est ici c'est bien
parce évolué après que l'uci s'est elle
pas eu 6 et alors qu'il ya de moins en
moins de pièces pour les blancs ok ok
une fois il a pris sur 2,7 et la navarre
a repris chevaux de selle bien sûr
l'évolution de la pause bienvenue dans
la loire doit votre gagnant il faut
quand même en est a pris sa tête f5
oui si je pense plus ou moins tout le
monde dos à dos huit joueurs parra
problème à 8,85 plus tôt mais tu vois
c'est ça son truc duda c'est qu'il a des
positions pourri et tout d'un coup il
doit ok c'est que dubaï world et sur
dubai contre 6 milliard pour m6 vous
pouvez cliquer mais ces matelas non ton
rêve six excellentes
c'est juste maintenant c'est un bref
cette c'est bien un excellent il le
healer foyot reprises et ce avec le noir
ok mais il a vu il a calculé qui avait
rien
by peter allen company ou d'ailleurs il
faut pas sous-estimer donc le juriste et
moi non plus oui mais pour l'instant
c'est que le moins 40 ans et moi je suis
malheureusement parce que je suis à fond
pour 8
malheureusement se monte donc pour
l'instant ce n'est que pour une
technique de jeu délicates
c'est ça me rappelle ma première partie
photos cochonnes
tu as joué comme ça oui j'étais plus ou
moins le jeu du même style enfin pour
les tactiques et c'est pas un compliment
et quand même je gagne et quand même je
viens et après la prise mardi après le
parti il m'a dit pourquoi est-ce que
vous n'aviez pas abandonner je dire de
vrais jeux il m'a dit mais c'est un
joueur de café paraît qu'ils ne sont pas
finis pas mal mais justement il était
quelle est le troisième joueur du mois
oui ce jour là fuient ils l'ont pas
gagné loin de réussir au mieux comme
beaucoup plus dopé il a vu à temps mais
sans fin qui les fait nul doute à dans
la partie précédente puisque avait juste
rien de base
oui ok moi ça c'est toujours so est le
roi du jeu pratiqué il se change pas
avec 2 o mais ici au musée mesdames eux
deux c'est une ligne très dangereuse
bien sûr de 5 par contre j'ai toujours
pensé que ce n'est pas beaucoup je
pensais qu'il faut des six faut jouer
ici je pense qu'ils soient fous de doses
soit roubles 2 je pense que malgré un
pion de plus je pense que les noix les
doigts parce que inévitablement à un
moment donné le cavalier voit s'avancer
sur des toiles sur détroit et puis sur
cinq est le pion de plus qu'on passe
c'est au story 5 rennes et comment tu
connais tout comme ça qu'on écoute
l'ouverture de pallanne tous été rappelé
le pr monde
[Musique]
d'ailleurs je sais je sais même pas
pourquoi est ce que ce n'est pas en
forme
quel punch line quoi l'ouverture le
quatrième est planté d'après mon nom je
sais pas pourquoi ils s'appellent est
toujours prête à l'heure parce que j'ai
pas des jets point je suis pas de région
ou par celle au sein d'air je crois que
c'est attaque au vert qui a inventé plus
ou moins la catalane si on peut appeler
ça inventé mais qui a commencé à jouer
des quatre des cinq avec grille 3 à tous
et je peux pas que conteur dernier
confirme à sculpter ou dis pas ce que je
sais pas je sais juste que de toute
évidence rcc moment d'après l'un deux
tournois à basseau je me rappelle plus
ou équipe mais je crois bien que c'est
artaq au maire qui a joué ça pour la
première fois à barcelone bailleurs qui
j'ose pour l'intérêt général et google
je sais pas il faut demander aux gens
mais en fait
on va leur demander vont nous répondre
mais tu sais que j'ai pas dis pour rien
cette anecdote sur tartas covert tu sais
qu'il a un point commun avec toi et un
point commun avec duda points communs
avec toi c'est qu'il est devenu français
et si je me trompe pas savelli tartas
govare ils étaient polonais non si je ne
me trompe pas où ils avaient un
passeport polonais il faut vérifier je
suis pas sûr je sais qu'il était de
l'alpi russe et a pris des vignes ou
conquois les citoyens donnant au trot
seront rois mais je ne sais pas si la
main passe par polonais mais j'ai une
autre question pour le spectateur
il faut et qui vérifie sur wikipédia
mais en tout cas une enfant commun avec
toi je sais pas et se targue déjà pas à
cette question pour le spectateur
pendant tes stream était est et vidéos
moi j'ai un discours j'ai une question
pour les pour le spectateur
vas-y moins cher ami qui est a été le
joueur qui fut leader a évolué en tant
que solide
maintenant tu m'as déjà dit une petite
indication ça a été aussi un jeu pour
voir si le sable l'histoire française
des échecs très riche et avec cette
question là je fais un extrait que les
gens se souvient quand même de les
brûler pop française où chacun les cinq
heures par an pas dans l'or
j'en ai 50 60 ans les cinq meilleurs
joueurs du monde
françois jacquier labourdonnais
pas de chance bon il n'a jamais
considéré le gourdonnais en tant que
sénégalais d'ailleurs le port d'armé et
vigneault nettement à plus haut
rendement trop pop star après midi
maxime vachier lagrave d'ailleurs écrit
sinon est ce que les spectateurs
parce que la spa ti aux deux fils et
d'orge se trouve sur comment s'appelle
le boutis - dodo lé pire à wes à les
gens le savent
normalement bon excusez moi moi je le
savais pas et du coup alors qu'ils
étaient sont égales personne ne sait oui
très facile de dire ça fait une petite
nul finalement hockey qui est ce que
c'est que ça sent cammas de reprendre
son son style à es9 d'ivoire attend
parfois il prend 2 peut maintenant parce
que prendre 2 e
ok tu sais a fait c'est sais tu
commences apple
moi aussi pendant très très longtemps
même si j'ai construit pour mon
répertoire des 5 au deuxième sur les
troncs pour ce qui moi je pensais aussi
que f obligatoires j'ai fait tout à fait
joué à voile et moi ya pas mal de jeu
reste toujours comme chez moi ici
mais si ce n'est que c'est pas terrible
terrible en fait f non mais ça égalise
mais c'est agréable à jouer avec les
blancs je sais je
d'ailleurs pour une fois je suis du même
avis que toi une fois je jouais avec le
voir un jour la russe il ya cinq ans je
pense je pourrais du tout aimé et donc
moi je pense que j'ai après juste
nettement plus fort envoyé au jeudi et
les joueurs sont parfois les joueurs
sont comme ceux bâtis vous arbitrez
aussi zarbi conservatif riz pour tous
[Rires]
ça me fait marrer quand une idée moi en
verlan mairie pousse ses parents se
trouvaient d'ailleurs je voudrais du
moins des spectateurs 100 demandes le
trouve bien sûr et sam demande vers des
compléments à qui peut-être ne sont pas
méritées et qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ma chanson avec la diva de tachkent
je pense pas que je t'ai bien mais je
sais que ça a plu aux quelques années sa
voix était intéressant pour moi de voir
votre avis de votre avis départ ici
jouer betinho kit contient sa carrière
de chanteur oui mais j'ai pas j'ai eu
peur des cds pour leur art pour les
sharks en aide aux pauvres pour le rock
mais si je suis dégoûté mauvais de
squelette était de jouer donc peut-être
ingrédients dans les partis je suis plus
ou moins sûr que les noirs sont ok même
si j'ai un petit peu peur de télévion
conversys lorsque le pion boyne se
trouvent sur ces quatre mois normalement
je pense ça doit aller
je pense que dans son coin de tout âge
parce qu'il va faire quelque chose comme
comme vanessa qu'en valais
trois rois qu'est ce que c'est que ce à
quoi qualifiant ce qu'on veut juste
faire tousser un c4 est attaqué en fait
j'ai en fait tu sais je pense qu'ils
jouent comme moi en fait
et c'est quoi un complément non mais
regarde mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
je réécoute de guérir mais je comprends
juste fois c'est quoi ce goût l'heure je
vois même pas pourquoi il se fait le
mieux placé sera que sur bois c'est
sylviane les echets non mais c'est très
bizarre la manière de fruits de tout à
écouter les gir moi je commence de
changer légèrement encore mais ce que je
vois pour l'instant c'est ce n'est pas
l'un des joueurs les plus doués du moins
je sais pas c'est un comédien c'est un
retraité de 66 ans mais là c'est
étonnant ce qu'il a fait quand même
voilà un lien de cuir des lampions et
trio pour un tel jour parce qu'il n'ya
pas de nous lire pas de mots pour cela
revoir
non mais c'est c'est vraiment très
étrange quelque chose savoir qu'est ce
que ce serait bien de pouvoir parler à
double après leur match
je voudrais bien de voir une explication
kamwendo plusieurs de ses décisions
d'aujourd'hui
tout est alors peut-être grâce à fabien
noël à ses possibilités
non mais attends mais c'est n'importe
quoi dans ce qui fait qu'ils continuent
de thermos quoi oui tout à fait les
raisons parce que les gosses sont que je
reçois mais moi je pensais avoir recruté
thauvin et gertrude recruter mitroglou
pas mais tu dois pas connaître mitroglou
nitot 20 mai dont les taux quand c'est
un mec qui joue à marseille meilleurs
attaquants d'europe plus grand potentiel
d'europe meilleur que lionel messi
non c'est une blague est un mec qui fait
des vidéos sur internet ils commencent
toutes ces vidéos comme
et mitroglou c'est un attaquant même si
je sais très bien qu'ils tuent au fait
qu'il peut définir familiaux ton
meilleur investissement rentable kourach
le témoin qu'il a déjà une équipe jamais
vu que je n'ai jamais vu un train de jeu
sournois mais je sais pas il a fait une
équipe kamski mais ils ont été éliminés
5 il a pas d'équipé mais maintenant j'ai
doudard je suis je suis bloqué quoi mais
je regrette j'aurais dû prendre artemiev
peut-être je vais apprendre artemiev
aussi quoi après le match c'est la crise
déjà dans non mais je suis inquiet la
pelade ce qui se fait vraiment défoncé
quoi et quand
ok d'un point de mieux que je peux faut
faire semblables comme quoi je suis prêt
des chiots de l'autre côté
à vrai dire mon cher ami chaque histoire
qui me ramenait du poignet hommes jeunes
aiment bien mais je pense que nous fait
souffrir comme les préparer pour ce
match pour le gagner quelques buts de
plus 3 tu pense qu'il va te payer après
le match ou que je vais que payer va
devoir encore te payer quoi y'en a marre
aps comme terry tune et le transfert du
royaume de poids jovial
c'est ça que tu vas faire une reprise de
comme d'habitude mais avec tes propres
paroles notiez faire peut-être d'amd 5,5
qu'est ce que je vois je pense pas que
c'est le présent le fin du fin de mois
parce que si dans le 5e assises dans vos
six d'un v6 donc dans 2-3 ce concours un
choix pratique mais combien de pions de
moins mais coigné if you ya un pion de
moins bien dans cinq
bien sûr il va faire soit tourache lutte
soit si je sais pas
on peut faire les noms mais moi j'avais
photo archives b mais pour contre la
huitième et south china fc jamais pour
rien oublié et où je pense que c'est un
coût qui se faisait quoi comme un papy
mais t'es tu vas faire tour j'ai 84 ou
tout cas pour ces quatre fosses des
droits ou excusez moi c'est quoi ce il
n'y a pas de tout reproche ainsi ce
fondement c'est un tour g8 roi c'est
cette dame à 5 mais je sais pas moi
cavaliers ce sens qui vous prend ses
seins que relève de 7 3 à 8 du ressort
tour à 8 à 3 qahtan a fait tout rachat
mais c'est peut-être bien joué et ce à
tout rachat en fait plus possible le
monde - de toute façon bas à vrai dire
leur fou de dos ce à partir d'un manteau
monde
qu'est ce que l'on veut mais aussi aux
canadiens semblent plus paumés les noirs
ont réussi à cherche pas en vision parce
que ça suffit
pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'est mis en
danger en exposant trous sont retirés le
voir je sais pas c it pas pratique veut
dire pour l'instant je dois dire que je
ne paniquons le ni comment l'auteur
large ni comble vrai dire je pense you
en bonne santé dans un bon état
battus 2 à thiers fossé en curling de
dohouk et bien sûr je t'aime et tu sais
quoi l'aider à leurs collègues d'autres
fins que le berne 25 dans nos cinq
échecs et à karaj me lecavalier cloué
mais bon c'est pas pratique du tout
parce que maintenant ils menacent
cavaliers prend b2 et il ya aussi tout
un tweet qui traînent finalement dont
hôtelier dans son intérêt de préparer
quelque chose comme tous nos kelly roi
prend b2 aux abdos il n'y a pas de
chercher un bouc est ainsi que la route
[Musique]
non plus là mais pas vu non pascoe bien
sûr voir point que léo faut sur le dos
que défend des relais ta sachez bien
trop fort et si un point sur vos 6 1
points à 2 sur le dow prend h4 et doit
pas y avoir de père pète bain sans
croissance où il se tient qu'à ses 5
vient jouer sur dame prend effet dam des
six mois c'est 1,8 d'amd cette dame 17
mai noté menace de menaces et pressions
pour la fin je vois pas de menace même
un nombre non sur b4 donc à l'eau aux
conquois pratique c'est faux at war n'en
fois trois fois
os 3 il faut trouver le coup surtout
chicago elle est noire menace ni n 6 7
et 6 3 il faut voir le hockey me doit y
en avoir
peut-être tourbe et de haas était tourbe
et de et d'en prendre trois
ok maintenant ça va pour sow bon il faut
dire qu il avait oublié bien plus que
moi et peut-être un peu plus que toi
même
ce soir je pas lieu tout ce qu'on aime
parler des bouts de leurs toiles que je
parlais excuse moi en tant que en
excuses il dire que je joue pas depuis
deux ans et demi parfois jeu là pour
l'instant elle peut dire que vous étiez
ce complètement foutu pour le voir donc
bien sûr ça va devenir plus donc le soir
pour sa pluie a plus d'eau ok orange moi
mon corps pour galber les tirer du match
et il a qualifié ces cinq pour menacer
m'attendre c'est vrai que j'ai dit
parfois qu'on peut les gêner parfois et
les jeux sont fait ils ont tous les j
com
comme c'est le cas d'au moins nuances
parfois c'est le cas de beaucoup et moi
parfois je ne m'intéresse encore une
partie en cinq minutes mais regarde au
visage il n'a pas l'air bien d'houdain
et l'air d'être inquiet et que puisqu il
ou prix pour ce qu' il leur faut avoir
de moi je pense que mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça qu'on le voie d'eau ne pas
avoir une seule ouverture avec les deux
poules mais c'est quand même des demi
finales du tournoi le clou le clou
comment dire de plus intéressant de là
mais quand même il faut savoir que
comment il ya c'est pas elle la ligue
promesses quand même les gorges du monde
mais tu sais c'est marrant d'ailleurs
que grid ou qu'il ait dit que c'était
sont moins bons souvenirs échiquier un
de toute sa vie
la défaite contre duda je sais je sais
ouais
comment dire
mais je n'ai jamais demandé j'ai pas eu
le temps de le voir encore après ce
match je n'ai pas eu une seule fois
ouais je me demande pourquoi est ce qu
il faisait de tels choix de youtube
contre oui quand il a commencé à jouer
la nage d'arte est rentré dans tous ces
trucs de fou j'ai pas trop compris non
plus c'était quoi besoin mais il venait
le soir
pourquoi est-ce que c'était leur peine
de rentrer dames et les plus compliquées
pressing les 6 et adopté comme futsal
coeur de thé comme se croient au
deuxième trimestre aux 3e tout le reste
mais au bond et d'ailleurs déjà pendant
le mois saint et et couvertures il a
dominé double dans les annales oui il
n'ya pas de mine et les parties non non
il n'a jamais dominé dans les parties
compliqué mais il s'est entêté à rentrer
dans les parties compliqué justement
mais commet une erreur
enfin je sais pas j'ai l'impression que
il y en a deux jeux très fort
analytiquement par wan yanhai je défie
de très fort joueur
si on parle sur l'échiquier et la 2e
après fois ci on parle de la dimension
psycho je pense que le soleil a pas
photo malgré tout les jeux cette
impression là je pense que c'est
l'histoire d'être bon 2000 génie au
niveau de la psychologie
j'ai l'impression que parfois les
joueurs de haut niveau ils comprennent
pas du tout où se situent leurs points
forts et faibles
c'est bizarre je pense que c'est très
compréhensible c'est pourquoi est ce que
je le pense
je pense que l'histoire des arts
chiffres aux échecs donc appartenir au
top 10 pendant plus qu'une dizaine
d'années quelque chose comme ça c'est
l'histoire d'un terreau tiff et donc je
pense qu'en tant que autistes dans les
formes légères ou aux fortes de plus ou
moins destinée de n'être pas doué
psychologiquement et je pense que c'est
bien ça le problème de pommade
intéressant j'ai point de vue qui est
très très très questionnable bien sûr je
sais que tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec moi mais je ne pense
depuis quelque chose comme 2 en cause
non mais c'est ton point de vue un tat
le point de vue que tu veux quoi fin
mais on a droit de pas être d'accord ou
pas d'ailleurs at on le droit de ne pas
être d'accord avec elle d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je pense que ces dernières
années la les dernières cartes en vente
1 je pense que hannah une avalanche d
autiste aux échecs au sepa enfin c'est
difficile à dire va te paraît avoir un
médecin pourra diagnostiquer tout ça
mais de toute évidence pas un auteur
comme on n'est pas médecin non plus mais
sait-on si ton ressenti quoi ok je dois
dire que con enfin je dois dire que
tour66 dans cette partie là c'est ça a
l'air d'être très superficiellement même
si je pense pas que le noir soit bien
oui tours 6e pour moi iginla sur
cavaliers point il veut fermer le
prendre des six daims prend des six
salles cavalli qui sera attaqué encore
eyharts faut se croire ok double attaque
je vais montrer cavaliers pro 1 puis on
prend des six d'emprunt des six pouces
et 3 protège le cavalier attaque la dame
menace le cavaliere donc il faut
reprendre avec la tour ce qu'il a fait
un tort c'est bien sûr parce que si sûr
bosser
j'ai l'impression que cet auvent 1,5 to
reprend ses deux il y aura foule des
quatre noms qui va arriver
donc je pense que élections organisées
des problèmes pour et la voix juste
aucun problème et -21 que millau au
sortir de l'élection
je pense qu'il doit être très précis là
mais tu sais j'ai l'impression que le
problème c'est qu'ils sont pas de la
même place en fait j'ai les pentes basse
d'autres le taux accordés avec toi ce
jour peut-être sow et un tel joueur avec
qui il faut bien se voir ses limites et
il faut pas jouer trop librement
il faut se limiter et donc louis tenir à
distance
tu sais pas qu'il est moins fort mais ça
me rappelle des matchs ou sur le pap y
était meilleure mais tu joues contre le
real madrid 1-1 et même si t'es pas
moins fort ok c'est le real madrid
n'était pas prêt pour et j'ai bien
l'impression que contre gries tchouk
écart yakine qu'il attendait pas à 100%
ça allait mais contre sautier hyper
solide hyper préparer et très sérieux il
manque une division encore la donne et
une kia son nom là par contre il a
suffit que je dise ça pour que le mec
dans une pièce sont d'accord c'est
génial mais cette fois ça prend des
chiffres qu'est-ce qu'ils aient leur
épure aux couleurs peut-être il a pensé
que la tour reste en prison non mais
c'est incroyable a suffit que je dise à
une mecque dans une pièce on en a mais
c'est incroyable
non mais ça j'ai jamais vu encore moi
j'ai vu pas mal de choses ça je me
rappelle même pas quand est-ce que les
dernières voix je joue au foot pas non
mais c'est assez étonnant non viens de
parler du haut niveau qui est différent
ça non mais en fait je pense qu'il a
calculé genre tout reprend et il s'est
dit sûr cavaliers prend ya fou prend
mais sur dame pranger pas fou des 6 et
donc il a dû se dire je commence par
fodé cissé sur cavaliers proches sur les
tours france et 5 et il a juste oublié
qu'ils avaient le pion qui protégeait je
n'accepte pas cet automne aux
explications des choses on m'avait dit
directement que c'est de la merde mon
explication non mais comment s étonner
que je sais pas une bêtise du génie quoi
parce que je sais pas question et
l'ombre lui passer sur ça je vois pas
d'explication de moi peut-être ton
nombre non plus au patio comme j'ai dit
depuis tout à l'heure je suis plus pour
d'otages aux six mois tu marques tu
construis ta retourné sa veste comme ça
incroyable comme d'habitude taylor pour
tenir ce nom mais tu vas pas nous dire
que t'étais pour karl scène ça jamais je
pense pas idiot je t'ai jamais une seule
fois pour casser car sauf sur le sofa
seule variable
ces camps et le jeu côté la tétée pour
qu'arsène donc toujours parce que je
suis content heureux que moi partout et
demain revenir il a vraiment aucune
chance contre dung quât hockey mes amis
je vous laisse pour d'autres ok ok pas
tout de suite m'a tout de suite
du coup la double s il va revenir matin
qu'à page est inquiétante on me croit là
tu es comme les jouets harry part et va
donc ouais début de match
début de match qui semblait super
compliqué pour sow qui n'était pas super
bien dans la cour
duda qui n'était pas super bien dans la
dernière partie est déjà menée par deux
points mais cette gaffe de
cette garde de sceaux a pu remettre duda
dans la partie parce qu'il tourne à 5 4
pour sow et c'est plutôt bien payé pour
duda qui a été assez mal dans un grand
nombre de partis
donc pas si tu pas si clair le match
d'un court devient tendue alors que ce
pensent avoir pris le l'ascendant mais
7,7 garde juste avant la mi temps c'est
un peu comme au foot de prendre un but à
la 47e minute avant la mi temps
genre tu mène 2 0 et tu prends un but et
il revient à 2-1 et du coup tu sais pas
trop comment ça va se passer on va voir
on va voir comment ça va comment ça va
tourner comment ça va tourner j'espère
en tout cas que vous aimez bien
attendez je vais répondre à un copain
mais bon il tourne bien et dont il ya
peut-être peut-être voir se remettre
mais c'est un peu le scénario des
matches précédents ou duda a semblé être
un petit peu distancé il était revenu
dans le 3 + 1 et après dans le 1 + 1
donc on va voir on va
moi je reste pour duda en tout cas cette
façon jusqu'au bout serait pour duda et
lattes qui retourne sa veste donc ça va
être marrant
ça va être marrant deschamps qui sont
pour ou la ddt
donc attendez j'ai vérifié j'essaie de
contrôler ça sent la pause
je vérifie que la partie n'en sait pas
reparti fort que je remette le chrono
ici donc
ce match ça va reprendre dans thonon 3
minutes un ça va reprendre dans trois
minutes et on va être on va être partis
comme des fous j'ai envie de dire est
reparti comme des fous qui va reprendre
incessamment sous peu mais 5 4 mais pour
le moment vous avez le score au dessus
et on va attaquer une nouvelle cadence
on va attaquer le trois puissants
n'oubliez pas d'ailleurs si vous êtes
nouveau sur la chaîne vous pouvez vous
abonner à la chaîne de chess com fr noda
qui semble pensif les mains on croit au
dessus de la tête et les bras en croix
au dessus de la tête
ok c'est reparti 4 alors il va compter
avec la sicilienne we make you il
contient que six pour éviter le flou b5
échec
il va retourner dans la variante qui n'a
joué précédemment
et si je me rappelle bien la vue des
problèmes dans une finale qui d'après
vlad été mieux pour les blancs en
attendant le retour de la drees c'était
cette finale c'est exactement ça
l'acquis en train de revenir on le voit
arriver et c'était cette finale et cela
nous excite finale était mieux pour les
blancs d'après leur dit ce qu'ils
avaient analysé qu'apparemment delà de
vlad on retourne dans la finale dans
laquelle tu donner un avantage aux
blancs ont d'après leurs aînés n'ont pas
moi moi moi j'aurais pensé que ça donne
presque rien mais je sais que
l'évolution d'orateur
et bien très favorable aux bois ouais à
me dire ça représente partie de ce
chèque que je comprends pas parce que je
me suis dit je leur ai dit que les plus
faibles et ces six à sept sont
compensées par les photos prises sur le
cas le plus probable et moi même ces
surfaces on leur dit comprend mieux non
le prg est toujours présent toujours
mieux que moi d'ailleurs parfois parfois
non par exemple je peux vous dire une
chose amis qu il existe des ouvertures
que l'ordinateur arrive toujours pas
contre le stade hier que me disent tous
qu'ils eurent affirmé
pour l'instant mais il ne sait pas c'est
bien le dernier endroit où ipsen pas
quand tu vas voir alpha 0 ou dida 0 où
je sais pas quel 0 qui va arriver à mon
avis ça va faire très très mal là dedans
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais compris la
turquie et les analyses avec alpha 0 de
sanair non pas ça j'arrive toujours pas
à comprendre pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
n'ont pas oublié toutes les parties
contre ce cépage crois qu'ils ont ont
donné 2000 assad lève qui en a fait un
bouquin ok il va sortir c'est ça peut
pas représenter comment il ya 5 heures
par exemple l idée de business pour
google pour que c'est bien trop puis 6
heures moi j'ai mon point de vue on met
les complotistes
alors du coup on va peut-être éviter non
je pense que dow nouveau et les échecs
sont utilisés en tant que modèle pour
crier leur l'intelligence artificielle
dans ces cas là bien sûr y'a pas trop
d'intérêt de teuhpu blir parce qu il ya
trop de potentiel commercial en tantôt
intelligence artificielle y compris par
exemple pour pour présenter sa en tant
que par exemple ton intelligence
artificielle chez toi non mais ça c'est
sûr qu'ils utilisent ça pour faire des
tests pour commencer pour pour créer des
intelligences artificielles ça c'est sûr
c'est un début en fait mais sa chance à
un test de sa chance depuis les pâtes
riz pâtes riz viande entre evian dans
les récits en fait de l'équipe
dramatique
peut-être pas tout le monde sache
interne aux spectateurs c'était toi tu
le sais bien sûr ça a été en fait le
début de cette histoire avec les
ordinateurs et qu'il bioéthique et s'est
pas aventuré que le père de lui
quelqu'un de tiko diplomatique m'a dit
oui c'est lui qui a fait le fameux test
de turing pour savoir si tu reconnais si
tu fais la différence entre une
intelligence artificielle et une
personne d'ailleurs
cette histoire est un conteur m'a dit
attention la deuxième guerre mondiale
commençait le si je me trompe pas le 1er
septembre donc toute l'équipe de l'epo
restait à nager tirs pendant les
week-ends et toute l'équipe de la grande
vitesse tout de suite retourné en
angleterre pour participer dans le
centre comment s'appelle de lady
cryptage a précisé ils ont fait des
joueurs d'échecs sont participe au
décryptage des anglais
oui et donc ils ont beaucoup apporté à
la victoire finale de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est d'ailleurs il ya joué un article
exemple et sur les questions très riche
mariage entre eux mêmes je me rappelle
clou ça a été écrit par qui sur une
chaise pour un con ou même les parties
d'échecs jouer ces fonds ne s'est pas
ses repères qui a écrit là-dessus ok
tout cas robinho va les parties amer
dans les finales de fou les bourreaux ou
non qui ont de plus mais je pense que
les noirs doivent pouvoir le tenir parce
que je vois pas comment masquer les bois
vont échanger le fou est rentré avec
lolo avec l'eau avec le roi sur but 14
je pense que normalement ça doit se
tenir
social faut que les blancs réussissent à
échanger le foot case blanche en faisant
quelque chose comme vous c'est de fouler
trois mois où les cases blanches je vois
pas avoir deux fois toi moi ça me
donnerait si ça marche je pense que ok à
vrai dire il est possible que je me
trompe ou moins moi je vais voter pour
que c'est plutôt vous le cul payant pour
de bon non ça va être nul ça voilà la
voie que les bois republic voir deux
fois ou deux mais est ce que ça marche
je pense pas parce que après tout
d'autres foule de réveil à 5 avec c4eva
prend 1,6 m'apprend et c'est peut-être
même les noirs qui sont mieux après le
oui donc on ne peut pas se permettre ça
et dans ces cas là il faut ici tout ce
qu'il reste au brass de recruter du coup
mais sont toujours fidèle à son style et
je pense pas qu'ils il existe un joueur
plus pratique se tenait à temps ils
essayent de la gagne et quand même de la
perdre parce que roissy doha spécial
soir 3 5 et 6 et qui calque et muse
circulent à ça par contre je joue cinq
affaires c5
on apprend à 5 maintenant les questions
qui a chaussé 65 soit super 5,3 à 3,7 ou
faire des cadres des trois prix droit b5
mais attend ses six prises droit ces six
mais ça c'est nul non ya pas deux
exemples là tu vas faire rager 6 3 et 7
non atteint il peut pas y avoir f5
mais quand le roi était en b 6 ok bon
mec que tu as des coûts est ce que quand
le roi est en effet si cela ne pouvait
pas y avoir un truc en v6 s'il pouvait
pas y avoir genre f5 sur ufc avait eu 4
et sur gf savez h5 g4 ça gagne et je
crois qu'ils arrêtent un gain je veux
non mais il a joué il a fait trois
quatre cinq
mais je crois que la première fois il a
fait 3,6 pour la première fois jean piat
férois bicis et il est revenu c'est pour
ça que duda a fait une telle tête après
je crois que c'est lié au fait ça a été
trop vite pour moi le logo sajoo c'est
par ici
et c'est pour ça que doux d'après la
partie il avait l'air écoeuré je crois
bien qui l'a fait roi b6 et qu'il y
avait un f5
maintenant je vais augmenter notre parti
ont maintenant je view à quoi il joue
cavalier d'oddo
peu avant à se retenir et c'est bien
l'idée que j'étais au milieu des années
90 avec mon staff on a beaucoup analysé
ça compte des habitudes et les joueurs
jaune adorent mettre un jour comment les
insurgés 3 pour les voitures noires ou y
mettre sur ça que faire pour ce témoin
sur la scène d'ailleurs je pense que il
ya un jeu qui en plus appelés français
qui a quelques-uns vont pas mais
français qui était drôle
le meilleur joueur avec le corps et sur
sa quille l'as maroc
non je pense je parle de jeu français
l'enjeu célestine mengue je pense que
donnera le meilleur a été depuis
toujours
comment s'appelle leur chambre il
chambre
et le juste et rigoler avec la bourse
commentaires sont collés sur cinq
ouais mais il a mis les excellents quand
il attaque le roi non là on se souvient
que lorsqu'il il mieux son cavalier sur
jeu 3 et un autre corner sur le coin se
souvient qu au début de l'histoire les
arabes ont noté les dents mal parce que
tu viens final échevelé les cheveux qui
arrivent de partout
oui me passionne ou de l'arabie saoudite
au rodéo au début rires tout simplement
c'est pour ça que les chevaliers la
maîtrise de chevalier à 6 ans comme chez
les kazakhs comme chez les dames comme
chez les arabes gelée naturelle fois en
fait en faites vous peut-être je vous
rejouez vous étonner avec très souvent
la fête j'ai tiré pas mal des
conclusions que s'est fixé le jour
différent par rapport à leurs rapports
alors comment dire alors à lyon héritage
culturel que c'est intéressant
par exemple lorsque je jouais contre 1
les joueurs de dos de l'amérique du sud
souvent j'essayais d'éviter les
positions bouquet et du coup tu joues et
tu joues et les positions ouvertes où et
pourquoi est-ce que je les fais tout
simplement parce que si on parle de
celle ici on par notre bureau les
massifs des montagnes à lui présent une
grande partie de leur pays et donc je
pense que c'est bien naturel de leurs
cadeaux dévoiler plus sont bloqués et du
coup vous que les joueurs russes tu
joues comme en haye a pas de règle ni
contre le jeu russe ni contre le jeu
je craignais contre le jeu utilisera
lire parce que trop de typage trop de
forts joueurs qui jouent de manière
différente lorsqu'on parle de soupirs
que ça sachez qu'il ne peut pas tirer
des conclusions tirer des conclusions
que si le prix n'est pas trop fort et
donc contre les français du tout comment
que ça ça nous intéresse nous
construirons contre des français jeu
jusqu'au bout parce que l'histoire des
maires pour le doubs et bien les locaux
bertin et l'important c'est de
participer
c'est c'est bien trop dans les vrais
jeux toujours pensé qu'on peut
l'utiliser mais où les vieux je suis
utilisé ça quand je dis venir deux fois
championne de la france et donc via la
foire y avait quoi rien de quoi être
fier au début je pensais que le plus je
continue le plus jeune est déjà sonné le
début tu pensais comme ça mais en fait
il ya peut-être plus trop de style en
suivant les pays m'annoncer sa tête ça
doit être très uniforme très fort mill
internet change tout et mon mothma ce
soit elle de comprendre dos les anglais
ont épié le présentoir parce que je suis
peut-être un très bon joueur
10 ionale un jeu russe c'est plutôt dans
les plus sympathiques voit pas il ya
plus de vingt ans parce qu on aurait pu
dire ouais genre il ya une vingtaine
d'années encore oui qu'est ce que vous
voulez je partirai pas c'est donc plutôt
traitement
revenant sur la partie je pense que je
pense que les repositionner tout à fait
correct pour les noirs mouais je pense
pas que les noirs ce milieu tout
simplement parce qu à chaque fois de
jouer avec eux avec deux pièces légères
coûts internes à tous et le kiosque de
points 6 passes mais ça lag un tout
petit peu et je pense titouan dans le
chat je pense que ton internet n'a qu'un
petit peu mais on va attendre au pire on
va recommencer la peine il ya peut-être
un léger lag et excusez moi dans ce cas
là je fais le maximum j'ai gelé mais en
attendant voici blanc non mais des fois
il suffit juste de redémarrer mais j'ai
remarqué ça a commencé a pas longtemps
mais on va on va voir normalement ça
stabilise tout seul mais si jamais faut
juste relancer l'appel normalement il ya
ça va pas être un souci
qu'est ce que tu penses de ce que ce
poids sur le chiffre n'est pas une
impression que une nouvelle fois se
domine dans les finales elles vont
gagner un deuxième guillaume
il va maintenant avoir gagné le
troisième bon ok je veux qu'on en avait
peut-être mais il faut prendre doté le
marcheur plus haut sur youtube
christophe com qu'est-ce que c'est
non par exemple c'est pas pour faire les
références bien sûr oui nous par exemple
la vie que à l'esad prenait toujours de
tels matches très bon c'est pas moi
important
non mais là je pense pas que ce soit une
question de sérieux vladan la flotte
juste qu'il est moins fort en finale
qu'à la tueuse it what you lie ex
concubine est sain et généraux qui ont
ils vont te l'occasion dû attentant il
était en train de l'arnaqué et après on
va essayer de relancer l'appel parce que
ça lag un petit peu mais ça mon avis ça
va revenir c'est juste l'histoire de
d'affaires inquirer leicester et c'est
fini à temps on va relancer l'appel vlad
attend une petite seconde
on va relancer je vais te rappeler on va
relancer parce que c'est un petit laguë
ça arrive
et donc on va on va rappeler on va
repartir de zéro on va rappeler
attendait une petite seconde
ça peut arriver donc je vous laisse
regarder la partie c'est une nouvelle
une nouvelle catalan et on va relancer
l'appel
si on y arrive ça vient peut-être de moi
en fait aussi issue possible mais bon
comme le stream est pas censé la gué
ça doit aller
mon latin tu es de retour
moi je voir pendant un court temps de
chien tu vas bientôt voir les chutes ont
d'ailleurs j'ai une petite histoire à
raconter sur les lots sont à temps plein
j'aimais l'échiquier mais tu peux tu
peux commencer à raconter l'histoire si
tu veux mais attends tu vas tu vas tout
revoir
normalement tu dois avoir week-end si tu
peux rêver lire s'il te plaît sur le
quatrième qu'au pouget de damas car oui
oui ici un récit mois riche amant d'un
curieux partie est très pénible et le
contre caruana
après que vale bout de cette foule trois
chiots une intéressante moi y'a
prescription qui sait pourquoi est ce
que dans ma tête
en tant qu il existe trois mini four de
cette dame c4 c5 et sur fond de sa faute
de cet écologiste fois émis d'emprunt
invités comme quoi c'est un problème et
le noir sont mieux donc mais il n'y a
pas beaucoup de monde qui au courant
donc et tout intérêt c'était pas la
peine d'en faire trop d'accent mais
juste pour les spectateurs qui
s'intéresse donc qu'est ce qui se passe
sur l'échiquier mais tu portes tu penses
que soe d'oudaï connaissait pas son cas
c'est bien sûr dauda connaissent pas
bien sûr et après tout qu'est-ce qu'ils
connaissent parfois j'ai l'impression
que quelqu'un derrière mimi joue bien
mais il joua reprend il jouait au moins
donc maintenant fera cinq ans que je
sais parfois d'octroi de total à sange
par benoît est assez intéressant sinon
je sais pas quel coup je rêve que je
pense que j'ai les boules j'ai bien
réfléchi à faire deux trois faux deux
sets par contre
j'aime pas les gueules du cher j'ai
l'impression qu'il est en train de
tomber
tombé sous la pression j'ai l'impression
qu'ils n'arrivent même pas à comprendre
comment il faut jouer contre les crues
très saine de notre époque donc balance
une pièce tout ce qu'il fait c'est tout
ce qu'il fait c'est ce c'est pas bien
tout ce qu'il fait il n'arrive pas à
aller la gagner un parc c'est juste par
hasard j'ai l'impression que au niveau
du style ou ignorés vos niveaux 2d style
ce ça va pas du tout pour jeune costaud
bagis tu penses que il n'a pas
l'habitude de jouer contre des
défenseurs de haut niveau comme son et
du coup qui souffrent ils souffrent et
graff
tout simplement parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on quoi elle est contre
un mur mouais je comprends tout est à
son raisonnement
son raisonnement se donnait pas finir
avec le score trop pourri pendant les
deux minutes et je pense qu'ils espèrent
surtout tête à l'espère sur les oueds
donc il faut qu'ils jouent des parties
non mais il est tellement dominé mais
j'ai l'impression que sauvé il lui fait
jouer les positions qu'ils jouent mal en
fait celui réussi par duda il réussit
pas à voir ses positions oui oh vous
comprenez mon année en fait sens est un
cadre de sa sauce m ce n'est pas facile
domaines d'analysé saut parce que je me
rappelle qu'en dire que l'exemple points
seule fois la pensée que
bon il ne représente pas le grand d'âge
mais ce qu à saint louis qui ont dédié
qui en a compris à quel point le niveau
6 qui au panda paris belgique sans lui
qui en a compris finalement qu'est ce
qui faut il lire comment y arriver il y
est comment s'appellent les comores le
film qui s'appelait lors comment
s'appelait ce film là le charme
irrésistible le futur wheeler soit le
chat irrésistible de l'état oui voilà
c'est bien sûr c'est bien sûr il est
laid pas très brillant ou des feux il
est fantastiquement forez oui
ouais ça se comprend qu souris qui a
voué à franck pour la première fois ne
comprends pas tous les dangers parce que
c'est le plus grand champ d'onal
non mais il a raté d'un match fou de
damages de ben si tu avais vus à stabio
la caméra qu'on est la fille d'un match
8 échecs les l'a pas vu d'un match de
moins à jouer moi non mais c'est duda
qui a pas vus à il a raté un bon signe
pour jean-christophe ok après dans le
sens qu'il peut abandonner
il vaut mieux qu'ils offraient pas ce
que vaut mieux de garder plus de parts
pour les restes du maccio prenez ce prêt
soler qui ne vise de toute manière il
voit une tête il veut traîner dans le 3
minutes et aller vers le une minute à
l'autre
il a tout l'intérêt de de traîner au lit
mais nous non répartis en 23 minutes
ok tour des quatre ou cinq ans il est
inquiet contrecarre yaqing ricchiuti
réussissait à en arnaque et plus des
partis
il est vrai il est vrai maire mais ce
qu'est ce qui les unit les deux auteurs
ne se voit pas limiter l'adversaire
les deux autres s'étant l'impression de
voir un combat de boxe avec sow qui a un
job tu vas une bonne allonge du gauche
les duda il réussit pas à s'approcher
non ok mais écoute et déjà je peux vous
confier que cette ouverture la l'état
liem oui tout le monde au niveau de
l'élite c'est que de sa couleur s'est il
désolé
c'est quoi cette préparation je dois
critique est forte et moi ça parce que
il ya une seule chose que je devais
excuse aux chèques seller finissent là
ok mais les jeunes vannes
ce n'est pas une excuse mais il a bien
mis là que 20 ans ok maintenant l
ergonomie c'est fou et ses soucis aux
fausses notes de salles les habitants
bien sûr fous de ça parce que dans le
sac n'est pas tout à fait précis
après fous de ça qu'il va jouer sur les
rangs comme le shit oies et les noirs
après c'est les doigts fringues à cause
des hallettes fois ci ce parce que ils
peuvent arriver
en fait ça ne donne rien de spécial mais
les noirs d'owendo doivent être précis
bayonne de 0,6 et qu après quoi les fans
pendant que les noirs ont obtenu
l'hélium parfait sûr que les fans et les
avocats comme 2 x 4 qui égalisation non
mais son souci c'est les ouvertures
ben non il n'a pas excellé cette fois là
à chaque fois c'est un problème problème
problème maintenant vous passionne pour
votre four b3 c'est le coup ça me
regarde sur la caméra ça se voit bien
que quand tu regardes son visage ça se
voit qu'ils ont sur ça se voit qu'il est
déboutée en fait quand j'ai eu
exactement j'ai vu exactement et que mon
visage quand même gagné côté de vichy
que t'intéresse pas lundi ok mais tu es
la différence c'est contre gries chucky
écart iachini il en arnaque et de temps
en temps la sauce et c'est
impressionnant c'est précis un oui je
dois dire que d'après la qualité de jour
peut être je vois le meilleur match sur
chaise comme the way sli
depuis tout le temps je n'ai jamais view
être aussi prenable et à notre câble
mais je pense que le style lui convient
parfaitement
oui parce qu elle se pose pas trop de
questions et se pose pas de restriction
à chaque fois à fait dans chaque partie
il fait chaud
comme quoi les coûts secure il les
cherche pas la vérité point d'autres ce
jour ce qu il
il voit par contre dimanche contre n'a
qu'à six qualifiés en finale dimanche
21h la finale bladi peur que ce soit un
peu légère non et ramon voir photo moi
je sais pour que pour les pondre ça va
être un match pénible parce qu il sait
que vos viandes mais à chaque fois
culturel de compte et on a comme moi
j'ai parlé plusieurs fois c'est pas
mieux perdre comme compte tous les
autres à chaque fois et le sou ce qui se
considèrent plus fort parce qu'il est
complètement clos avec le network plus
fort aux chèques mais trop souvent elle
arrive quoi que le prouver mais n'a
qu'un il est fort en médecins bailly les
élections génère je vois ce que je
voulais arriver tôt d'avoir joué les
tournois de rire quand dans chaque
partie de moi ambiance wagenbach soi que
dans soit moins bien et quand même il
marque jana plus en colère et j'ai
jamais compris cette comment s'appelle
cette alchimie qui est ce que tu penses
qu'il aurait pu être un clone du monde
ça c'est infernal
déjà parce que il y croit pas déjà parce
que je ne crois pas déjà parce que il ya
monde arabe
ils attendent que carson par da
notamment par les échecs et puis donc il
va réussir mais à vrai dire en tant qu
on recommence apple insider je te dire
qu ils travaillent même presque plus de
deux ans il a lâché d'affaires il
saignait complètement à la bourse ne pas
être mauvais il le cache non pas
d'ailleurs il se mêle contre les toits à
la bourse
et les check points maintenant c'est une
priorité le croire il n'est pas le seul
chose d'ailleurs je pense que peut-être
rien mais ma valise et il pense que
quand c'est le tellement génial que
peut-être
inévitablement il voit partir des échecs
comme pour ma fille est là tant que ça
pour sauver mais ce sera peut-être trop
tard
mais normalement une telle approche bien
sûr se prépare vraiment parce que les
échecs que comme un vulgaire mme stein
samedi les échecs centre il y aura
normalement les échecs pardon pointer
les proches cette position vlad tous
avec les blancs est ce que tu penses que
c'est bien ou c'est juste égal bon je
sais à propos de cette position beaucoup
moins que sauf parce que les jeux ça
plusieurs fois y compris compte je pense
qu'il connaît vraiment bien ça mais
d'après les gueules j'aurais jamais
pensé qu'il est noir qu'il veut voir un
problème dont l'un portait qu'il
soutenait total c'est mieux
peut-être car elle est déçue que les
noirs doivent attardé avec tyro costiou
hijikata qui arrive mais je dois dire
que je suis très loin data csd tu vas te
prendre 5 et je vois pas trop un
problème pour les blancs va être mais
pour les noirs pardon
je sais que tu as d'ailleurs fouache 7.5
de tels cas mais il faut encore montré
la précision moi j'aurais été exactement
et du moins ma victoire ici et beaucoup
de cette structure de pion dans le
premier match du championnat du monde
entre stein 0,14
c'est la première fois que je penses tu
pouvoir garder ok ça m'intéresse
énormément maintenant d'ailleurs mes
chers amis je vais vous avancez que au
mois de février je voudrais bien
débarquer à cannes pour faire la
première vidéo de vendeurs à propos de
les critiques c'est moi je m'intéresse
énormément de tout ce que l'histoire
j'ai appris pas mal de choses ouais très
souvent kevin qui me choque parce que tu
connais toujours de choses que je
trouvais pas parce que je dois préparer
des vidéos si tu vois moi je pense que
ce jour ce que l'information sur sur les
voies l'information en russe et la
formation en français souvent des
éléments non mais là j'ai juste fait des
recherches personnelles sur ce match
mais bon j'ai remarqué ça mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ça qu'est-ce qui calcule
la met juste ils feront ensuite non mais
c'est du bliss quand même non mais on le
voit à l'écran normalement il peut pas y
avoir de problème mais bon j'ai regardé
les stresser à l'écran - de quoi tu as
peut-être et stressé parce que son
ordinateur a planté où il se passe
quelque chose où ils regardent les plus
connectés à thiès comme de connexion
direct ouais c'est pendant la partie
ouais voilà là pour voir jean christophe
ça par contre c'est pas mérité cela il a
merdé vu ça fait un plus combien de gens
plus tard le scad à la salle devient ce
sinistre histoire c'est que si tu viens
à cannes pendant le tournoi de canon
pour organiser une soirée d'ailleurs
avec un grand plaisir et j'espère que
notre dvd 1 victoire qui viennent y aura
du succès parce que j'ai énormément je
préparais énormément de choses déjà je
pense que tu vois apporté pas mal de
chose toi aussi parce que à chaque fois
tu connais ce que je connais pas je
pense qu'elle va sortir un bon truc en
février j'espère qu'il va pouvoir faire
encore beaucoup de travail qui nous
attend là-bas énormément une fois je
commençais ça j'ai même pas vu la france
j'ai même pas vu la fin de l'histoire
tels moyens du bord ou parce que tout le
monde part de la politique mais je
trouve que ni les américaines au début
nico tôt pendant les mandatent n'ont
jamais su où il louait assez bien le
sujet non mais c'est compliqué comme
suivre c'est vaste
c'est donc je le dis parce que les
échecs politiques les courses mythiques
en fait c'est 15 points c'est aussi
grand que l'union soviétique
bon donc quand vers 3 je crois quand les
3 3 c'est presque toujours
lundi ce que tu sais pas quoi faire je
pense qu'il est possible que les voies
après pour les lignes à l'eau il est
entré pour un autre les prés de toute
évidence les noirs nourrir les six
livres nombreux indécis loire une
position très confortable après par
exemple il faut je sais tu que les c4 fo
17,6 à tout ce que vous voulez mais ok
une autre fois gugava jouer sur
l'échiquier et pour l'instant ne l'a pas
votre véhicule et elixer est ce qu est
ce que tu penses que après la défaite
par des connexions wesley so aurait dû
lui rendre la partie avec les noirs bien
sûr que les heures et le soir du russe
il n'y a jamais de yaya jammeh de
l'épicier c'est dur les petits eux
n'existent juste pas d'ailleurs c'est ça
ce que font les différences entre les
meilleurs joueurs du monde les autres
ainsi que nous on peut avoir les pieds
pour l'adversaire mais que je sais pas
un sentiment qui connaissent la pitié ce
jeu ça n'existe juste même pas comme une
option chez ces gens là surtout chez les
plus forte comme car c'est un cas
pauvres kasparov sa jours jusqu'au bout
et si tu perds à 10h10 et unir leurs
0,10 c'est paris qui voit pleurer
pourtant ça et c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'ils sont plus forts aussi une envie
de gagner supérieure à la nôtre
bon maintenant de nouveau on voit que
les noirs ont noté mais il faut
améliorer par les who de l'ouverture
bien sûr les noirs sont mieux parce
qu'on ne peut pas se permettre de tels
luxe crown damas quatre relais à 3
c'est bien trop donc je pense que
normalement nous devons avoir des temps
durs pendant cette partie là parce que
les cool les coudes de noir ses poules
confondues la dalle de sexe torride
comme les 5 tout à coup j'ai quatre au
lieu de kovalev ça ça coule de compte de
la russie
c'est tellement naturel c'est tellement
facile de jouer avec le droit à l'eau
mais non je t'écoute j'entends dire le
chat en même temps tu t'écoutes vie que
les gens disaient que c'était pas de
l'appliquer mais de la sportivité tu as
été répondait dans le tchat
ok pour vous voulez peut-être avoir
formé le plus précise
je sache bo5 surprenant je pense que
c'est le premier signe d'aller au match
qui au sens sans la confiance totale et
donc n'a plus pur dorian y compris
bouger les hommes ce que forcément il
faut que ça je pense que c'est de jeu 55
c c'est le signe de très grosse
confiance ce qui n'est pas habituel pour
soan jouer comme ça c'est pas du tout
son style voilà mon poids du tout donc
comme je connais très bien le typage
c'est d'ailleurs quand il était gamin il
jouait beaucoup de manière beaucoup plus
agressive tu as est possible que duda on
le revoit dans trois quatre cinq ans
avec un style complètement différent
will pour cela il faut se débarrasser
des complexes dans les virtuoses qui
n'est pas le cas ailleurs il a joué les
salaires très très très intéressant
comme le carrefour de quatre fours de
tata fois où est donc le 4 avec les dos
d'âne 84 là maintenant car le 5
je sais pas c'est quoi l'évolution de la
pression mais il est passé gold corp
cowell et c'est celle des pêcheurs bio
avec et ce qui est inquiétant c'est que
de nouveaux tu vois c'est duda qui en
retard sur la pendule égard d'ailleurs
moins gore
ouais pour l'instant je pense qu il est
préparé quelque chose sur bois ou sur b4
à vrai dire je vois enfin pourquoi
seniors ils perdent pas le pire c'est ce
n'est que du joug opportuniste je pense
c'est bien le cas j'ai l'impression
moi non plus voyez la même tête il veut
faire [ __ ] anges le cadre des 5 tu
vois choses normalement non mais
peut-être jaloux chômage aussi dans le
doubs il fait et le coude de subway
ouais ouais ouais sainté - terme via ce
qu'on a dit que élire pelouse mois en
panique parce que ou bien sûr ici est
celui qui peut être moins bien mais il
est juste un peu moins fort mladin mais
bon il apprend il est juste un peu au
moins 1 fois ou peut-être il est juste
neuf mois
ouais je pense pas que ce soit si nette
bladen c'est juste que ce soit réussi à
l'amener sur son territoire sur son
terrain mois pour pouvoir régner casse
auto ton terrain les faux cul ture
plupart tentent heures à dire que c'est
un genre de lyon oui mois le temps que
le terrain c'est quoi ton os x en
général ses joueurs il est venu pour sam
walsh et avec les membres complètement
vide et c'est pas un bon signe pour son
futur parce que s'il peut se [ __ ] d'un
tel match complètement c'est que
peut-être il peut se [ __ ] complètement
monde de sa carrière
non mais je pense pas à vlad byers
problème éternel d'ailleurs des
keep you elles sont parfois à trop tour
eux mêmes pas parfois mais trop souvent
on bien trop cordiant doit leur histoire
ok mais il est jeune la diva qui la
prennent peut-être qu'il a trop pris la
confiance après avoir battu
great fouquet cariat qui né comme ça tu
peux tu peux atteindre toute ta vie pour
te retrouver à 35 ans non mais il va
peut-être pas se retrouver à 35 ans il a
le temps de réagir à 20 ans à 20 ans il
est déjà 27 40 quand même c'est pas mal
nous élèves ça va être intéressant pour
moi est ce que il va connaître bien les
cds c'est vraiment parce que dame de
cette je pense que c'est déjà pas les
meilleurs courts parce que je pense je
connais des simples et plus forts si
vous voulez j'ai une expérience énorme
sur cette ligne là je lui il faut aller
plus loin et je sais que comme les décès
des conquois plus fort justement à cause
de 5
ok rial l'autre agit bien sûr parce que
fout simple les noirs jours dame du wif
au 6 mai moi j'ai toujours essayé
d'éviter salle mais sympa parce que
depuis tout à l'heure tout ce que tu dis
qui est bien ce le fait dans l'ouverture
quasiment tout ça d'être le jeu en élite
il connaît ce coup de main c'est
impressionnant comment vous savez c'est
impressionnant il connaît tous nos îles
et les cailloux pour cela et les
précieux comme cela parmi ses relais
dans le tournoi mais ils ont une mémoire
ils ont une mémoire impressionnante
c'est incroyable ils refuseront pas
ouais tu as eu raison et foi quant à
comparer de tels joueurs a bien pris si
un parent de voiture est bon c'est bien
ça a été comme péjore l'eau ou du moins
depuis d'aller contre bouteille
bagnolet les vitesses cosmiques cosmic
non mais c'est incroyable ouais je dois
dire que je suis hyper impressionnant
pas comment où et se joue ce match et aa
parle d'une seule partie il a presque
jamais de fautes extraordinaire ça il il
montre l'exactitude et la précision de
fisher price et il joue même pas son max
parce que je trépigne à lille il charge
les pieds c'est joe si vous voulez à ce
chemin sainte rousset français et
l'autre arrive parfois mais bon c'est
parce que c'est le style qui lui
convient blatt c'est vraiment le style
qui lui convient que tu as peur tu veux
dire
au niveau du style que l'auteur joue
plutôt aussi de en tant que deuxième
erreur oui mais dès qu'il a plus du mal
à être exact quand ils jouent contre des
joueurs plus forts vous mettrai pas s'il
veut pas voir et j'ai pas pensé à ça
mais il est très probable
ouais qui c'est qui vient doit en tant
que spécialiste de boulettes de tête
dieu tout à tokyo s'est chargé d'aller
d'aller couler j'aimerais bien te dire
que oui mais non
la différence de niveau me paraît trop
grande et wesley joue assez vite et il
ya cinq points d'écart il faudrait
qu'ils reviennent à trois points tu vois
mes cinq points c'est beaucoup
s'il revient à 3 tout est possible
encore mais d'après ce que je sais de da
à nos excellents
surface comme lorsqu'il s'agit de brûler
non mais il est très bon mais ouest gso
il va pas être mauvais non plus si l'ue
mais plus 3 ce sera déjà bien
tiens d'ailleurs tour ce cadre est
peut-être très très bien joué parce que
menace de jeu tour cartel autour de
cette très très bien mais il est
monstrueux on tourne autour de 5 6 est
très dangereux de jouer puisque tu vas
fait bien rire cet excellent excellent
excellent d'ailleurs un grand coup et je
hais tout de suite presque parce que les
noirs normalement viol évitez quand même
de jouer ici c'est parce que ça fait
face à celui trop le ciel mais il va pas
avoir le choix vous normal que jouer ok
moi j'ai fait plutôt tour quand l'égypte
comptera quatre ok l'idée est bien
compris si vous les lieux tout faire
pour priver les noirs de la case au sol
pour le coller non il se bat bien ils
menacent dam d'un échec un petit piège
bon tour 6-4 bien sûr avec les détours
de ce simple et donc je continue de
poser les bonnes questions
bien sûr les chefs spectateurs vous
allez comprendre
on parle pas à dio de la proche de sow
pour cette partie en tant que l'
approche parfaite en parle de son
approche en tant que
la proche couronne de leur zotac qu'est
ce que les 17 tours de ce sale con
walesa donc de re 5 d'abord ce qu'il a
bien fait de faire un fils mouais il
faut faire quelque chose
moi je n'ai joué que six avec les deux
tours ce sens que les deux cas à coller
de quatre matchs pataude et k4 dames
entrent enfin parce que je pense que
c'est la meilleure façon de donc et
surtout aussi si la roë vii il enferme
la tour et surtout scott
il ya comme les 2,5 et surtout reprend
yves et damas mais j'ai l'impression que
duda il a besoin de jouer de manière
très active moins deux autres moyens
après que les trois roues en f1 pour
l'instant je vois pas comment est-ce que
ont pu remonter les bois bah je sais pas
qui coûte le fruit moi je n'aime la
crise à toulouse en effet tour 17
autour de 2,7 je pense mon poids que
mutuellement allez voir que vos skis si
quoi que ce soit wah wah wah dirigeants
et tour des six margot +5 ma part bien
sûr lionel et facilement des oies
ça c'était quelque chose dure avoir un
empressement empressement ok le reste
bien sûr c'est de là à voir des 4
roy au centre d'affaires tour 3 sur la
scène mais c'était bien joué un mort ok
pour l'hôtel coup comme ça qu'il doit
punir parce que 5
est ce que c'est moi c'est de nouveau je
dois critiqué jean question parce que
c'est bien trois en fait il qu après l 5
tu vois jamais gagné kiloutou que
peuvent qu est-ce qu il est fort risqué
quand même la mahatma donc comme google
on regarde ok ça à faire nul mais le
père roch wamytan incroyable à
l'incroyable la tour comme ça mais bien
jouer jean christophe avec deux
centièmes de seconde sur la pendule est
ce que ça gagne question à il est tombé
qui est ce que dit il il est curieux de
voir ça
autant jouer moi je crois que les
cavaliers pranger 3 et est juste si rami
droit dans le coin et c'était fini je
pense et je pense qu'ils avaient pas
avec sa connexion avec son ordinateur
bon maintenant il va fuir à la manière
de jeu s'oppose à non ya une manière de
jouer sa com
bordeaux prendre sur six blessés dans
deux ou trois il ya une manière à la
camorra domaines en langue nationale est
de jouer sur le fait que soient nos
charges l'ifo soirée notre passage
donc oui les choisit les manières de
ical ou non mais écoute c'est quand même
dommage qu'il ait perdu la dernière sa
référence à et tu peux faire plus 4 au
lieu de + 6 à vrai dire pour moi c'est
plus de moi je pense que ça fait une
heure déjà que je sais pour l'amérique
et met un peu de suspense là d'un peu de
panache je comprends ça ferait un
montant déjà que je suis plus haut pour
jean-christophe parce que c'est quand
même c'est comment mener ce que ça
voulait devenir comme ça et je veux
qu'on te la jouer comme on l'a
maintenant ça y est il rejoint ces
insectes et du gosse avec son communiqué
ça m'étonnerait silva pas puis
maintenant avec le bas aussi ça va
devenir bat parfois contre celui ci bien
bizarre parce que aucun besoin non
malades c'est difficile mentalement pour
pour pour jean-christophe il en a perdu
une sur des connexions là il enterre une
otan c'est dur quand même les événements
sont pas en sa faveur
peut-être dû apprendre 2e mais ça paraît
bizarre je comprends mais je suis devenu
ils pointent savoir intelligent parce
que les échecs cet angle les échecs
c'est un sport très raide
il faut toujours prier et 5 par contre
c'est sympa mf5 c'est vraiment
incroyable parce que normalement un faux
pas d'un tel coup tout est arrivé pas à
m'envoyer ouais il est il qu'on voit un
peu aux insultes les yeux non mais c'est
pas je suis déçu vlad moi aussi en
quelque sorte
qu'est ce que tu veux de 1 à poil le
spectacle à chaque fois à mais anna
comédiens anna vient de témoigner ce que
s'est passé au moins cher pour les
couronnes comprendre
malheureusement c'est pas toujours c'est
pas toujours des tournois comme à saint
louis où où avais-je casey qui peuvent
être considérés comme le plus
intéressant malheureusement parfois à
quelque chose non mais c'est dommage
parce que ça promettait beaucoup et duda
les événements tourner en sa défaveur
quand même oui mais la montage pages que
dans cette partie
depuis quelques couleurs est plutôt dans
son élément tant qu'il faut jouer
irresponsable et juste bouger les pièces
ouvert son adversaire là je pense qu'il
est toujours pas mauvais donc qu'est ce
que la photo mme lucie je suppose ou 5
puis 4 6 là je pense qu'il est tout à
fait dans son élément c'est bien c'est
bien ça c'est cette position là où il
convient parfaitement et je pense que
cela elle va gagner et donc minimiser le
score canon
moi en 4 - 5 - 5 ça va faire déjà pas
mal et après moi aussi ce même y je me
marre je pense que ma des bas mais là
c'est la dernière nuit tombe vraiment
c'est cruel c'est cruel
c'est très cruel d'accord - peut pas
tout avoir
non non mais tu as marck pas d'autre qui
rit intérêt je veux quoi ici avec le
ballon à fait fou et 6 h 5
et s'il faut aussi soit chute
je pense à cinq quand même et foule
trois peut-être mais j'aurais dû
calculer
je pense à vrai dire que h5 ça c'est
ariane j'aime moi je veux tout oui j'ai
fait pareil gérer photo soldats pour
garder l'oeil sur le plan des cadres je
pense que j'aurais fait la même chose je
suis pas sûr effet un puissant qu'un
patient mais probable parce que mike
mack
il est possible que je me trouve que je
pense qu'il est plus dur de trouver le
coup pour le noir pour les noirs que
pour le bois peut-être fou b3 fous ces
deux se mettent une idée dont je parle
de noir je sais mais hier après pour les
mains ok mais les brames je suppose les
doigts mais là faut 3 par exane matthias
et deux sur fouet trois mythes anciens
12 et densité pour ça que cette hausse
acculé le jouet faut ensuite parce qu'il
parle dans cette lutte a donc dû faire f
3,3 g ii avec les blancs ont peut-être
le temps me direz vous et pour
pour doter le coucou coucou 3 oui oui
des cibles et moi il n'a pas de doublure
de hockey mais là c'est complètement
fini non fou g5 eh oui la dh au symbole
c'est un bandeau direct et grenat ce
matin quand même trois sets
et qu'est ce qu'il faut c'est vous bref
ou 7 ou 8 c sur l'inquiétant détroit
facile ouais et maman fouet cette de
telles choses ne marchent jamais marché
il reste quatre minutes 27 la dernière
partie de trois il ya + 5
et là on peut dire que sur la séquence
de trois minutes c'est quand même un peu
cruel sur sow qui a perdu une une partie
gagnante en tombant
ce qui est rare avec la seconde de
rajouts et une partie sur des connexions
franchement si on était à moins trois se
seraient pas ce serait pas non plus du
vol 1 c'est donc la dernière fois que de
3,3 normalement oui à moins ce qu'elle
soit très rapide donc pour la première
fois je pensais jouer le guen des dos
d'âne et qu'est-ce qu'ils vont sortir
ici ok mais il va la perdre et je vois
les perdre je vois ça un jour pas comme
ça qu intéressant c'est juste une
technique assez idiot ben moi je pense
plutôt b3 avec les défauts de 3 et le
colonel richard h quatre essais - pas la
bonne version de cette finale parce que
le foot doit rester le plus on doit
rester chez toi là c'est horrible qu'ils
arrivent à ribeiro f5 et tu as juste
dominés stratégiquement moisson fut il
faut que les cavaliers se tape ça je
sais pas par contre parce que je trouve
que les c4 dotée des danses il faut
prendre sur cette cave de c'est pourquoi
fo de trois juges auraient pas fait
gérés jouent en bo3 bien sûr moi [ __ ]
c'est mieux
ouais moi je ne passe plus le fait je
pense que c'était pas ça et maintenant
je pense les noirs sont ok france 3
était le coup au lieu de feu de troie
parce qu'aucun abandon poil avantage de
dauphin andy qui ont été à moins-16
n'avait gagné les deux parties sur des
connexions et autant brimer ok mais la
partie où il a perdu où il a perdu sur
des connexions il était moins bien quand
même
donc est ce elle l'a perdu autant
c'était pas dit qu'il devait vraiment la
gagner il a aussi gagné il faut rappeler
celle où sera donnée une pièce en un
même on a géré les combats ne sais pas
j'ai pas le compte des parties gagnées
j'ai le score mais j'ai pas le compte
des parties gagnées j'ai l'impression
qu'ils veulent gagner de près et c'est
bien s'est bien passé ça peut pas
respirer de gagner un maillot des
léopards
voilà donc que va laisser aux quatre
nouveaux jeux point du tout aimé bout 5
je ne pense pas que ça passe ça il
affaiblit la casse ces cinq oui je pense
qu au niveau de son choix
du coup il est rien ap l'hystérie
j'avais dis donc je pense que au lieu de
voir un bon avantage pense lui il a
beaucoup aidé au cours de raucourt de
dany leprince sur f5 ses cavaliers f6
attention déjà fait cinq six matches
mais calmes à 9,6 en plus qui mènera au
cas où il veut la mode bat il pensait
pas quoi faire
lamotte miles pense jouer retour eu 6
rue 6 5 mais je passe le bon coup et
peut-être voici celle mais sur quels
points 1,26 franc d2 ya de ça rien de ça
non mais peut-être cinq cavaliers 6-3
7-6 et prend 1,8 fou prend des dents il
a peut-être raison peut-être des deux
qui traîne
mais c'est pas pour gagner la partie des
têtes f5 sais pas si yo bon dans ce cas
là que toute erreur mais bon avec 100 kg
un cavalier c5 aussi juste l'échec en
fait bêtement et le fou en achète il est
moche
ok là cette position dollar un peu plus
son jeu n'est que les possibles de ce
que tous ceux 5 200 carif après tout ce
sanctuaire 5 a réussi leur retour à toi
toi pas mal aussi
ok c'est carrément un nouveau titre au
sein de notre époque modèle je suppose
que l'air maintenant il est préparé le
bouquin pour ne pas risquer rien du tout
pour juste garder le gore est ce peut
être dangereux b3 b4 après pour gagner
peut-être fait bouger si c'est et
comment tu passes bah je ne pense pas
que j'aurais sûrement rire je passe mon
coin je veux rien faire je veux juste
garder la pause tu faire une nulle mais
les pâturages 5 juste je pensais qu'il
allait faire plonger 6 pour empêcher
tout rage 5 mai l'ipad cuisse juste tour
à shanghai le pion coup droit quelque
chose je sais pas je pense vous qu'est
ce que le prix plein qui elle a joué sur
les sur le thème tactique même bien sûr
une fois les noix les boire moins longs
[Musique]
mois sur bordeaux qui a pas de thème
la mahatma un que je tour 6 3 c'est bien
sûr c'est pas cette fois de tout laisser
nos méthodes auxquelles la position s'il
ya quelqu'un qui peut être mieux ce que
les bras en fait c'est clair vraiment le
plan de sauce et qu'ils vont prendre
aucun risque qui blindent la position à
un maxi n'empêche tout le jeu tactique
est double
il se perd un peu dans l'étape un peu
contre un mur dis moi qui est ville
qu'est ce que tu préfères ce mois chez
eux en blitz ou le moins chiant à
londres non c'est matthew mitcham -
watchers pas trop intéressant mais plus
intéressant qu'elle peut gagner à des
retournements de situation il se passe
des choses c'est juste que c'est un
match un peu trop à sens unique mais
sinon c'est sympa quoi en fait j'aime
bien voir les pièces bouger j'en prend
un certain plaisir tu sais qu est ce que
je te comprend ici d'ailleurs je pense
que des fois un froid bien placé
d'audard n'a pas bien traité dernier
coup et je pense qu'il ya un train de
voir de problème la posture et la
turquie va rentrer en f5 ce n'est pas vu
ça parce que 12 5 twh 6 comme il ya deux
trois ou jeu catalan est bafouée 4 il ya
qu ils sont là maintenant c'est réparé
mais c'est qu'il est mal autant comme
toujours il y aura de nouveau trois
secondes inquiète en france c'est fait
non mais il n'a plus de temps à vrai
dire il est parti en contre la montre
michael parfaitement lpo parfaitement
abandonné incroyable quand même
l'admiration totale de sens il est juste
plus fort jusque mille fois plus fort et
donc je me suis trompé dans mes oreilles
d'un mois pronostique c'est quelque
chose qui joue la deuxième fois que tu
te trompes pas très longtemps
nasri qu'est ce que vous voyez james en
pâtit donc parfois malheureusement moins
comment s'appelle monde attachmate
personnel qui regagne ma fille
malheureusement votre regard garde s'est
pas assis que là encore à il a fait le
mystique petit pont soit pas noyé une
petite pause mais il ya déjà moins six
blad écoutez donc bien sûr les jours
sont fait bien sûr son regagner le -
ch/la excusez moi je vous préviens bac 2
3 mais notre parce que je vends mon clip
c'est magnifique ça non mais ces essais
c'est difficile pour 12 dallas - 6
mais bon la dernière il méritait pas de
numériser pas mieux que la défaite c'est
dur quand même
c'est dur mais bon
ce haut et plus fort c'est tout on peut
rien y faire c'est comme ça mais je
pense pas que ça se remettent en bullet
pour duda parce que sow est toujours
mieux au temps il joue plus vite mais le
problème c'est que sow il a trouvé le
point faible de de duda et qu'il appuie
dessus il le domine vraiment dans toutes
les positions techniques vraiment dans
toutes les positions techniques les
finales et tout ça il est plus fort et
il réussit à tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps à voir les
positions qui lui plaît ce qui lui faut
et c'est un problème c'est un vrai
problème
mais bon tu va progresser duda encore il
est pas mauvais c'est juste que c'est
juste que soient les plus forts c'est
tout c'est un peu bête à dire mais c'est
ça sa classe est supérieure et il vaut
mieux aux échecs c'est tout
malheureusement ou heureusement mais
c'est comme ça
avec robin poilus il lui manque les
ouvertures pour lui faire mal ouais
c'est ça il ay réussit pas à imposer son
jeu
il réussit pas à imposer son jeu
donc juste en train de regarder ce qui
se passe sur internet
non mais là puis si ça me parait dur
hein je sais pas comment il peut
remonter je sais pas quand il peut
remonter jean-christophe ça me paraît ça
me paraît très compliqué
la f1 mouvement qui gagne la section
bull est qu'il ya une deux trois partis
au début pour avoir un frisson
au moins pour avoir un frisson pour
avoir un petit quelque chose
épisode nice il installe la fibre il
peut remonter non mais peut-être
peut-être qu'ils affichent déjà très bon
c'est cruel à perdre la partie qui n'a
perdu qu'il a perdu autant mais bon il
est tout le temps à l'otan aussi donc ça
se paye un d'être tout le temps mal
autant comme ça ça se paye un jour ou
l'autre ça se paye un jour ou l'autre et
ça s'est payé ce soir
mais bon à mon avis duda reviendra que
plus fort et s'il revient avec des
ouvertures ultra travaillée il peut
faire mal mais j'ai peur que comme
beaucoup de joueurs qui sont arrivés à
haut niveau il soit obligé d'un petit
peu modifié son style et jouer de
manière moins agressive on vas tu es
revenu là tu es revenu est ce que tu
pense qu'on a plus de 5% de chances de
voir duda gagner je pense que la main il
en a presque plus ou parce que les
différences togo de plus si c'est pas
facile de compenser camin et les
différentes vallées boulet doit être un
gros test pour pouvoir récupérer sa
danseuse raid grotesque il faut que ce
soit grotesque je l'espère mais je ne
sais pas optimiste même si je suis à
fond pour le polonais est bien trop diop
à ce qu il faut gagner quoi il faut
gagner +63 partition qu'il faut gagner
sept ans quelque chose comme ça ok juste
ne pas pas six mois les quel dommage
qu'il déception parce que après
cmaj pointer compteur terrel qui ne joue
que ceux de nos formats de
jean-christophe mois l'armp aliments
beaucoup de chevaux c'est horrible tous
les joueurs dont tu es fan ait eu
déçoivent
ah ouais y'a kyo ya que le bateleur du
rap pogonat et qui me déçoit jamais
wojtek en lui déçoit jamais il déçoit
jamais d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui est
derrière moi qui viens discutions tu
peux me dire est ce que les boîtes du
rap sont aussi populaires en france
ouais c'est assez populaire parce que
réussir c'est de loin le plus grand
nombre dans le monde c'est non mais
souhaitons c'est peut-être pas autant on
populaire en russie mais c'est assez
populaire 55 millions de la vidéo audio
puis bat le plus populaire ok ça y est
ça commence donc faut que deux le
dernier un déluge ce qu'on appelle
lorsqu'on sait pas quoi faire un jeu
sous les dehors avec les bois
non moi je peux jouer ça a même quand je
ne sais quoi faire et la dernière des
lieux c'est de bouger l'opium sur le cas
tintin que tous ces parfaits
ce qui a été démontré une nouvelle fois
pour chaque média pour moi ce que je
fais généralement c'est que le boulot
premier coup vlad n'attend pas tu vois
qu'ils viennent tu peux assurer que moi
aussi j'ai dû au talent vidéo les grog
mardi police car ce même heat shock
laminant grichka de rsa mais il a
regretté seule chose
il m'a dit la vidéo est génial non
pourquoi est ce que t'as pas gagné ouais
mais c'est dur d'ailleurs je viens
commande ou est ce le jour ce partenaire
parce que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
jouer les boulettes il faut jouer avec
l'esprit est un entrepreneur jeu il joue
actif il a donné la qualité mais il
attaque de partout parce que lorsqu'un a
amené à marcq du timbre il est est
toujours plus facile de jeu pour
l'attack deux fois dans le roi parce que
je dois vous dire d'après mme tout mon
expérience analytique lorsqu'il s'agit
de la défense le monde moi tout le monde
mourait juste le monde est mauvais le
défendre ton papier mais là il s'en sort
pas mal regarde il a réussi à faire gros
rock va faire tous rêvent de il a blindé
et la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que soe
mieux classés en bullet que duda aussi
oui mais est ce qu ils voient se voit
fouet contre le poème comme l'ère bush
justice est-elle d'un rockeur l'as
monaco park au volley ok fois ça je
comprends juste redire
est-ce qu'ils vont recevoir fleurs qu'on
me fera dames c'est sûr qu'il débouche
c'est palacio les délais c'est pas le
seul pays à élire un point d'autres
étapes a tout repensé et trois non ça va
mais à 3 aïe aïe aïe à tour des huit
oui ok c'est pas les coins du monde
tout prend 0 à 100 inquiet mais il faut
qu'ils défendent la balade un peu de
suspense un peu de panache
s'il s'agit de panache les pendants des
zones toujours là d'ailleurs avec dale
scott sow a composé une boule piège sur
dark traya votre d'armes 3 babou
lecavalier arrive en attaque maintenant
assez durs c'est pas que soyaux sont
obligés de s avérer vue assez horrible
ok un peu en bandeau mai
et que l'esprit libre parce que de
telles positions ne sont pas défendables
avant tout au tout ce que vous voulez
qu'un pion pas signé qui est-ce qui le
pratiquent ce mac a dominé super forme
ok moins chers amis français on peut
dire que l'anneau juste plus forte chez
claude est écoeuré il est écoeuré de la
fois jeune homme écoute tu joues pas au
parc machines thomas nuire à peu moins
pas au départ je vais détromper sur
lescar y avait que +5
je m'étais trompé ça va donner un
mauvais score
donc il voit enfin fou tu rentres
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours pensé que c'est
le court le moyen de cette position j'ai
pensé que fou et 3 ou danse dollé dokou
son mieux
c'est quoi le problème en fait que
chaque année le problème c'est que dans
ces structures de pions la case parfaite
pour les basses pour le choléra cédé 3
rue et il n'est pas facile de le ramener
ici tout simplement parce que la torche
cours seront donc c'est ça le plus grand
problème des boîtes mais peut-être qu'il
n'est pas si mal là dedans mais
peut-être à me casser direction
n'appartient pas à ma cadence bolide que
tu étais un jeu reste toujours bien trop
académique mais c'est génial on fait
toujours une bulle est comme tu jouerais
en partie longuette f6 et préparé six v5
il d'ailleurs maintenant il faut trouver
le couvert et emblème comme ça oui
qu'est le qatar et la fois nous faire
mais c'est bien sûr une très grosse
concession après quelque chose qu'on
voit à quoi que ce soit cisco l'histoire
g5 quand même peut-être là il faut faire
avec
sap je pense que pouvait faire était
plus intéressante tout de suite au lieu
de te re scène parce que tu as est ce ça
aide pas au noir un écran tout fait mais
j'aime toujours bien de noir mais qu'est
ce que vous voulez toute ma vie et je
joue j'essaie d'y aller bien sûr je suis
toujours plus tôt deux côtés de noix non
mais là c'est une super instant bien non
oui oui bien sûr là maintenant je pense
que c'est juste que cela ça mais ça me
ressemble d'ailleurs à la partie de
wesley de chou à paris que les périodes
presque sans jouer parce que elle a
dribblé le lancement et la vache lâche
je crois bien sûr avec le ber cavalier
226 qui on prend founou g4 non ça marche
pas ou la cavalerie j'ai cinq ans mais
ça va aller très intéressant à ses
partisans la main comme les locataires
est passé ce qu'il fait mais avec une
finale très compliqué pour les bras
parce que courbet vite combien tourbe ou
8 pas pourquoi on va papa
ok fait un test il a menacé tour g8
échec est hors jeu de la finale je pense
le juste combat
ok il revient à cinq points fatigue mais
c'est pas fini vlad
vinci gagne celle là il revient à 4
points 1 essai s'est tendu tout est
possible
allez vas-y jean-christophe on est tous
avec toi comment s'appelle le j'ai vu
les policiers venus poste qu'à away ça
veut dire vivre le prologue quelle
culture battue c'est en fait la vague
promesse
récemment en tout cas son prénom
ressemble un prénom français
anna nous les russes se marre comment
s'appelle à adopter énormément des mots
comme debré nom de brécé c'est pareil
pour tous le savent
ouais on a pris pas les appliques en toi
tu connais le moins oui on a appris ça
je ne pourrai donc la dsca les polonais
vont nous apprendre à retourner un match
et abattre ou est ce les sauts dans le
money time
oh je le pense pas je le sens pas mais
je l'espère je l'espère mais la normale
idée assez claire il veut ramener son
corps est sûr b3 pour par pas sûr de toi
moi s est bien trop comment ça se
vérifie ciel académique tout admis je
viens le moins qu'en 2001 matin par
exemple 3 dont 2 3 c'est sympa qui
aurait pas qu aux plus ou moins tout
beau récit d'après leurs coûts et
d'après leur façon de traiter les hurler
l'ouverture 1,5 à main pendant tout le
match à 5 1 en opposition mais ça vient
surtout des ouvertures val je pense
ouais mais tu me caresser si je parais
zone mais gelé prévue avant le match
dans une ambiance qu un problème qui
auront aussi dos d'âne pas capable de
résoudre les problèmes dans les
ouvertures qui leur alloue des
difficultés non mais ça tu l'a prévu
mais bon tu avais pas prévu qu'il allait
perdre
oui mais trop dépendant de son président
là je pense les noirs gagner je vois
même pas comment le droit y a même pas
d'un mas 2 puisque le fou contrôle dans
cette de cette horreur là parce que
toutes les cases appartient à nos
mémoires ok il a trouvé ça mais
peut-être un coup comme des 2 et 6 qui
est désagréable vous faut b3 et des deux
préfèrent cavaliers f1 ici mais c'est
fini et on vote madame aux oies il a
évité les chutes et lui prend 1,3 ok
mais les lettres aux forces et les trop
fort ce mec-là et ses serres lolo le
travail qu'il fait pendant ces mois chez
joe summer jaune je cours je tire mon
chapeau bas mais il est vraiment très
fort parce que duda il a été hyper
d'anjou en bullet imagine qu'il avait
résisté à great chioukhs et il avait
fait mieux que résister et gris duke en
bullet il est vraiment bon et que
recevra d'ailleurs ça ne te pas le cas
et encore oui il a cofondé il a fait
beaucoup de cette fois parce que il
comprenait idiot compte envoyer les
stations chasse c'est que domine pas
trop dans l'éboulis et donc il a
beaucoup se préparer il s'est beaucoup
préparé pour cela fini ok il continue
toujours ce que celle édicules en
espérant pour le battre mais ok c'est
pas pour le teigneux non mais
impressionnant mais c'est impressionnant
ce soir je pense qu il est il des
terrains ballet final tu sais tu sais
combien je me rappelle plus exactement
mais je crois que magnus l'avait battu
avec +15 ou +18 l'année dernière wesley
c'est juste pour te dire le niveau du
mec c'est quelque chose non plus au
compteur magnus
chaque fois ça ne dépend beaucoup de la
psychologie et marion se ferait sans
problème mais s'inquiète pas faire du
massage ceux qui jouent plutôt pour le
joug actifs
ça n'a jamais été probants problème pour
la d'ailleurs elle va gagner de nouveau
à jette hors jeu si ce que le sable je
vois même je vois même pas le nom ni la
fin du moins cher c'est triste et on
nous dit que ma nièce avait perdu avec
18 points d'écart avait gagné conte avec
18 points d'écart contre sow il ya
monsieur pessoa qui par lit que ça lui
fait trop mal de voir sa part est
exactement la frange est cette dame
assise non dans machine ce roi quelque
chose comme cette dame a fait un bond à
marcel badji six premiers bien joué
enfin c'est pas les échecs ça au hockey
il est lé concours pratico pratique
surtout rev7 il veut faire ça il ya
peut-être tourage cette même hockey à
vrai dire qui viennent excuse moi pour
ce que je veux dire maintenant mais je
sais même pas comment
commenter ce qui maintient cavaliers ou
cinq fois qu'il avait vu une partie de
championnat on n'y a pas longtemps aux
olympiens pour moi c'est à chaque fois à
chaque fois c'est c'est c'est incroyable
qu'à chaque fois les noirs ne sont pas
préparés pour se tenir sur la voie ce
que ici cette position là et il est très
dangereux à chaque fois ça me surprend
pourquoi elle ce que les jeunes savent
pas que sur comment les cintres le mur
où cette personne c'est ça être joué
d'ailleurs par mamediarov contre le
cartel ça n'a pas été réputée au plus
fort niveau mais je pense que cette
position là qu'on voit maintenant je à
vrai dire je m'en fous ce que
l'ordinateur dit mais je pense que les
etranger je pense que les boissons
nettement mieux avec lehman lalique
ordinateur avec tout ce que si moi je
vais parce que il est mille fois plus
facile de jouer ça avec moi mais là
c'est déjà pion de plus mais ceux qui se
débrouillent pas mal quand même il a
réussi à créer des trous et d'un point
de vue pratique pour le bullet c'est
peut-être pas si mal ce qu'il a fait
cette fois-ci mouais si t'es pas bien
que t'es pas bien parce que tu ne veux
pas jouer cinq là maintenant comme les
aucun cas obligatoire faux et 4 2 dans
mon cas bien sûr normalement par les
nord dont cinq heures ses contours ces
trois vallées sicilienne c'est moins par
ses cris fils de la qualité donc il va
attaquer le roi mais tu vois bouddha il
est toujours obligé de jouer pour
l'attaqué mais sony mais même quand il
est moins bien se défend mieux que duda
quoi mais bon c'est peut-être aussi due
aux matches
tu sais quand tu prends le score
psychologiquement c'est dur
moi je dois dire que c'est incroyable
qu'à membres qu'ils poids mais l'effort
qui est ce que j'obtiens avec les
membres
les fonds manquent pas de talent mais ne
faut même pas de liberté à ses jours ce
que bush qui est le bien comme quoi on a
l'impression que chaque maman sait qui
est le bouton d'eau touchés non mais si
je dois dire que et tu sais je sais pas
facile de comment s'appelle je suis pas
magicien tourbe et de peut-être je suis
pas facile de pour dire de telles choses
mais je commence je vois comment elle
joue ensemble et je pense que je vais au
titre en effet massacrés ouais je pense
qu il aurait moins point du jour où il
est juste je veux pas trois fois plus
fort que trois fois plus fort que moi je
pense même pas que j'avais pu enlever
les à moi je et le macho en glisse 2002
minutes à piles de nom mais il est
vraiment bon et d'ailleurs je sais très
bien c'est quoi son point fort ce quoi
sont plus forts adressés
j'ai eu une discussion avec eux avec une
fougue ni incident et fit maths il
n'était pas d'accord avec moi mais je
pense que je c est ce qu cois son point
fort il sait toujours ce qu'il veut un
problème la vitesse à laquelle il allait
mais confrontons la position qui veut
obtenir et si la wii dans la direction
que avant les parties décident de hockey
là je viens je dois faire mieux les
feuillus là je viens je veux aux
tourtières et à torturer mon adversaire
avec les bois là je viens et je vais
jouer risque à chaque fois il sait ce
qu'il veut et c'est ça le problème de la
plupart des jeunes avant venir sur
l'échiquier et saufs quoi qu'est ce que
cherche mais la plupart du temps il veut
faire nul non souvent ouais c'est pas
pour toi
n'oublions pas pelleter locarno ti
grande pétrole
pendant longtemps avant curaçao 19 72 ou
c'était plus ou moins anonymes en choeur
ils venaient venir pour ne pas perdre
et pour une fois élus et les vivres dans
un tournoi pour gagner mais oui aussi
ils comprennent très bien ce qu'il a
voulu
c'est pour ça que c'était le cieux le
dos comme réserve tenir la tête à motegi
est ce que tu penses que le fait
qu'aujourd'hui et tout un business avec
les seconds ans qui est plus d'argent
plus de responsabilités dans les échecs
ça crée aussi cet univers des nuls parce
que personne ne veut perdre sa place
dans le cercle des privilégiés
on va dire le top 15 mondial et que donc
chaque audience à tout le monde de faire
ses petites nul ça c'est facile à dire
c'est que ce pass aux échecs moi et moi
je n'ai vous que rookie vous êtes
fabiano reste à jouer le match
bien sûr vous comprenez que si vous
faites signe les cellules avec des
locaux leur bien sûr on comprenait très
bien que hier il ya une vague des
responsables et comme chacun d'entre
nous est assez pratique et comprendre
que peut-être hier à pointer l'occasion
de 17 fois donc il faut ça parce qu'il
sait que maintenant elle et les milieux
du sponsoring vont pas s'interdire donc
ça se comprend télé et elle est
heureusement de kerret kintélé rosendo
fraga n'a donc pu ressembler lieu de
tout mettre
[Musique]
après loana game cube d'eau de perdre
trop de temps ouais donc il joue la
sécurité financière
oui mais parce que c'est le destin
c'est l'histoire de will de sa famille
de sa copine je sais pas du tout ce qui
autorise d'ailleurs ouest sauvé un train
de gagner notre parti et donc à vrai
dire je ne sais pas comment commenté
ténois sa domination mais samassa craint
donc là je pense que jean christophe a
abandonné ça m'a surpris plutôt qu'il ne
l'a pas fait mais de toute façon il est
visiblement il va le faire
non mais tu sais vlad de jouer ce genre
de format je vois qu'on joue les arrêts
n'a effectué que fitch s.com c'est un
peu la même chose qu'au obligé de jouer
jusqu'au bout un même site et où vos
dans les choux et les parties
s'enchaînent et c'est juste hyper dur
mentalement quand tu as compris que tu
avais perdu en fait tu tu peux plus en
fait ça que je la regarde déjà pour
saurait plus neuf
oh là là et il a presque aucun du temps
pour la faim depuis dix minutes
ça peut faire cher c'est comment dire le
cerf c'est le taux de chômage pour
jean-christophe parce que jean prince
comme pour sa carrière prochaine vaut
mieux que moi je suis aurait été fier de
plats d'une bonne une bonne question
dans le tchat qu'est ce que tu penses
des jeunes prodiges iranien moi c'est
que c'est extraordinaire ça et vous
savez et ils sont aussi bien que pas mal
de monde parce que ce sont des
tricheur moi d'ailleurs je ne pense pas
donc pas mal de monde parce que c'est
local tellement ils sont gays j'ai
jamais entendu parler de ça mais bon
j'entends dire pour jean tasiaux parler
sa pointe une fois moyen plusieurs fois
aux jeunes
cinq fois déjanté nous parler ça par
exemple quelqu'un a joué contre furent
usa sur autre chose qu'au bien ici sur
cette fois four et interviews contre lui
en demi contre 19,2 me navre guinée
c'est possible je viens jouer quand il
revient il est vraiment bon mais je
partageais déjà mon point de vue je le
pense pas mais je vous fais que citer le
point de ce que je fais
oui sinon ils sont extraordinaires mais
qu'est-ce que voler c'est normal mais
est ce que ce n'est pas ton pote qui a
dit ça qui pensent que tout le monde
triche se passe au fait qu'est ce qu'on
voulait c'est plutôt normal en fait
n'oublions pas les récits de chicken qui
a été au reste il dh et les perses les
indiens mais les annonces d'un autre jeu
quand même je sais puis donc les arabes
européens et vigneault qui au plus tard
donc c'est je trouve c'est le taux
normal qu'ils hommes et les reprennent
leurs animaux et d'ailleurs you fuck you
les indiens ont commencé de gagner tous
les tournois de tous les qualifications
de jambes ça reflète plutôt l'état
éternel de chose jugée
mais pourquoi nous les français on est
complètement dans les choux
je pense que tu connais très bien les
réponses j'aimerais bien voir ton avis
ces logiciels d'éducation mais les
indications générales où le système
français aux échecs
le système français aux chèques le
système d'éducation parce qu'à chaque
fois qu'ils auront à naham jeune prodige
à chaque fois une fois et les
sorte de l'école à chaque fois
l'impression départ année un nombre pour
qu'ils arrêtent et les deux échecs pour
que identique avec les études et la
pression de jose contre laval et
malheureusement france il y en a pas
dans tes le système comme en russie ou
bien aux états unis comme comme un
sportif de haut niveau peut avoir des
commence à payer plus avoir des regrets
des diplômes ok mais ça se rêverait pour
plein d'autres sports si c'était que ça
on serait mauvais dans tout alors qu'on
est bon au foot je rappelle que malgré
la coupe du monde quand même on est
champion du monde en faut le savoir en
russie elles ont beaucoup plus de
volonté que les angoisses continuer leur
carrière en foot parce que tout le monde
espère pour la jungle ok mais d'un autre
côté même en moins de 16 ans on n'est
pas on est déjà mal mais tout le monde
de muay wattao aux moins de 16 ans aux
moins de 12 ans de moins de 10 ans par
rapport aux chinois et indiens tout le
moins de mauvais hockey vrai nom mais
c'est vrai peut-être il faut que je vous
raconte ce que je connais par rapport au
système chinois pour les religions non
mais tu peux tu peux s'intéressant de
façon à les parties sans massacrer
vous voyez donc par exemple il y à un
jeune prodige qui s'est développée dans
une ville provinciale
et qu'est-ce que donc le gouvernement ne
propose il vous propose la bourse pour
anna l'appartement accueillir pour un an
et à ses parents qui lui propose le
boulot pour tout est à nous et parce
qu'il est beau échec parce que les ondes
achète donc et il a toutes les
possibilités de se développer en barnum
si le monde poids des résultats les
vraies choses c'est le système qui n'a
pas existé chez les soviétiques par
exemple qui existe
chez les choses là et ça non de résultat
dans tous les sports vous voyez nous
c'est c'est eh bien la route à suivre -
est malheureusement un peu passé moi je
n'ai un tel système dans un système
capitaliste
ça pue ça peut exister que dans le
système socialiste
mais non c'est sûr ça peut pas exister
en france un tel système mais au foot ça
existe un petit peu dans le sens où les
clubs lille payne et les enfants les
prodiges et il engage même les parents
pour travailler en amont au foot ça
existe je dois dire que le système
français est mauvais le système en
france et ailleurs est maire
ça tient plus haut pour ça tient pas le
coup par rapport aux tigres asiatiques
qui ne se soit des noms bon gars il va
encore perdre du danon je pense que
c'est bien foutu ou à 6 au 17 mai ok
comme d habitude
ou est ce les jo de manière pratique les
peut faire assister d'un une fois un peu
deuxième fois un peu 3 il faut appuyer
faut un petit progrès là donc enfin way
sli s
fidèle à son style et qui a finalement
un piège mais ça va pas marcher
non mais il est devenu monstrueux wesley
ans et une fois qu'il a pris le dessus
à vrai dire l'aller
la dernière heure je le feu qu
contempler à mettre en grand style et je
si vous voulez et je te dirai à vendre
et sa façon de jouer les dernières 60 70
minutes
samaras fiche et le tellement il est
bien tellement elle est bien les
conquois ajustons touchant c'est
impressionnant oui comme quoi c'est
quelqu'un qui dira de devenir championne
du monde parce que les chèques c'est
[Musique]
carrément il se retrouve aux échecs
comme le poisson c'est le trop belle
mais je pense que devient champion du
monde en jouant ce n'est je pensais pas
si mal pour une seule raison parce qu'il
est content parce que il est bien dans
sa peau mais tu prendre malgré magnus
malgré moi news parce que il est bien
temps de sa peau en fait vous savez il
ya un hic rival russe qui a ses camions
en france afin par exemple
jean-luc chavanon vont à parler le
connaissent et il s'appelle chaleur et à
un moment donné c'est trop de trous et
il se retrouve à bourgoin première fois
jeanne dix ans la deuxième fois j'ai eu
dix ans et il est des choses très
intéressantes
il y avait un seul type de gens qui
étaient bien dans leur peau voilà
c'était les croyants c'était incroyable
qu'elles sont ne pouvons plus les
invités personnes ne pouvant plus les
moyens de leur assiette je le dis parce
que parce que la fois leur
leur a permis de survivre quoi que ce
soit et là je pense c'est plus ou moins
la même chose avec eux way sli
il est qu ailleurs et 100 m2 très bien
au point d'armes sa carrière non mais
c'est vrai qu'il a l'air assez heureux
quoi sur les images et même en général
quand il joue il a toujours l'air d'être
heureux bas chaque fois que je le vois
je vois juste quelqu'un de très content
il
il gagne elle fouille où il perdit toute
manière il est toujours sociale il est
toujours bien d'autres 113 et donc mais
c'est pas souvent le cas par exemple moi
je dois dire que en tant que second dans
ces dernières temps là je suis plutôt
mécontent que content parce que parce
que toujours trop de soucis puisque tu
en as marre de perdre toi je mets - non
je n'ai pas marre bien sûr mais je dois
dire que pour l'instant my way comment
dire mais sa mission du joueur ne sont
pas réalisés en tant qu en tant
qu'ouvrier d'un projet six échecs et
d'albérola là encore une gaffe tokyo
home premium
ok il fait la gueule maintenant oui il
doit faire la gueule bien d'avoir le moi
je pense que parce que enfin je te dis
c'est que je pense à propos de la
préparation du doodle est là tout
l'intérêt de trouver le budget pour
mouiller ou bien tu es payé pour qui
tout est cassé
oui je sais ça va encore me retomber
dessus cette histoire on demande ce
qu'est ce que tu penses quel serait le
niveau de bobby fischer aujourd'hui on a
besoin de moi on a déjà parlé de sa
souffrance
le génie et ça reste toujours un génie
et leurs yeux ce dôme et le 8 il y
aurait près pendant les mois
plutôt celle du monde c'est pas salé
question qui m'intéresse ce qui
m'intéresse plutôt ce qui est du niveau
au riz ou filet d'eau s'il est assez
intéressante du caniveau oreilles
philidor plus intéressant que se trouve
la tse la dernière partie du match
est ce que tu penses que duda peut la
gagner pour sauver l'honneur quoi une
petite barbe ont sauvé l'honneur non
mais ça va il n'a pas fait un si mauvais
match je crois qu'ils vont gagner c'est
là parce que je sais que ici soan soan
dos d'ânes et de chevaux il fait tous
les coûts nécessaires mais ça appartient
pas s'apaiser
qu'est ce qui les force au quand même on
l'a vraiment vu aujourd'hui
ok f1 dans un match 4 h3 même ça c'est
pas mal de tours de c'était encore plus
fort mais tu peux pas jouer l'ouverture
comme ça sans nom mais c'est juste un
niveau stratosphérique pour moi blad on
voit vraiment la différence entre un
joueur et aux alentours de la 20e place
mondiale est un mec qui est depuis un
moment dans les dix premiers et 10 15
premiers c'est moi ou quelqu'un me
demande ce qu'ils fument dehors pense
que c'est un troll c'est parfois longue
et que redire là-dessus été coupée à
monter moi ce qui fait de lui le gêner
deux échecs face c'est plus rangée lise
échec france est clairement oui bon dos
tout le temps mais il y avait tout ça va
peut-être la gagne et vlad finalement
est ce qu'elles voient leurs frères
d'armes f2 f3
pour cette torche et deux oui je pense
que oui je pense que peut-être là
quelque part après cavaliers leucate son
impression montrer les précisions ça se
comprend aussi quand même parce que le
score était maintenant qu'il est pas
facile de rester aussi consacrer qu
avant mais d'ailleurs elles mêmes
passions que l'évacuation soleil non
mais il défend tellement bien on en met
à rêver tout rêve cet été il va prendre
et roy g2a okilélé comme fou
complètement partie un cocon norme est
incroyable et externe à mes tours fc
experian trouvé avec des secondes sur la
peau nue je dois féliciter mes amis avec
un très grand match de la part d'anne
d'hébergeur je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a
un mac témoigné le niveau
stratosphérique de la base maritime à
jean qui n'a gagné 9,1 en bullet oui
maintenant je me mets moi je donnerai à
van avant le début je pouvais même pas
le on a pensé que duda pouvait revenir
en bullet et il a juste pris encore plus
mais bon on souvent dans ces matches
quand tu lâches mentalement c'est fini à
face à des joueurs de ce niveau là
en fait me passionne toujours tu sais
très bien en tant que jeu
d'oublier sa grille et que l'oubli
recevoir par les bras vous eh oui donc
une fois et sio il surfe sur le voile ça
y est tu te sens moment touchant une
fois tu la vache ça y est tu peux perdre
10 parties non mais oui ça marche sur
les vagues mais bon là le match le match
là dedans dans tous les cas il à
souffrir d'aucune contestation soit à
dominer de la deuxième troisième partie
jusqu'à la fin du match sans jamais
baisser le régime on n'a pas n'a jamais
senti ce que duda pouvait revenir dans
ce match
la bomba plâtres du coup on se retrouve
avec fabien donc toi tu seras pas là
pour les demi-finales deuxième demi
finale et la finale donc deuxième demi
finale demain soir hikaru leeuwen et
puis le vainqueur afrique a roulé vonn
ou probablement hikaru en finale
dimanche soir 21h et on commentera les
deux matches avec fab
merci aux amis à très bientôt et
j'espère ne pouvoir comme en quelques
jours sur la chaîne gulli stream qui est
de roanne les meilleurs chiens aux
échecs y compris les russes les
anglophones les hispano les espoirs la
faune bien sûr merci merci sur ce bonne
soirée tout le monde et on se retrouve
demain soir ciao ciao